I'll good morning morning everybody it
is 9:30 already um we are going to
recess the hearing for just a few
minutes but if you would just please
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the of
the United States of America and to the
repblic for stand one
it's pretty
cck guy y let me show you what we did
care
for
e
okay with that we're opening the public
hearing on Senate Bill 315 and I invite
bill good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Shannon chandley I um have the pleasure
and the honor of serving the people of
District 11 in the state senate that's
marac Amherst Milford and Wilton I bring
before you this morning um SB 315
relative to law enforcement agency
reporting information concerning bias
crimes um I am pleased to
uh introduce this bill um to your to the
body I know that you have heard similar
legislation this was uh entered in uh
passed by the uh Senate Judiciary
Committee and on and the Senate um in
the full Senate of course and is on its
way to you um we know that New Hampshire
is a very safe place to live we hear
that often um and we're all very
grateful for that but we also know that
New Hampshire like much of the country
uh may be experiencing an uptick in bias
related crimes or hate crime bias
motivated crimes or hate crimes um this
is this bill is a way to collect that
data and understand what it means and
how to use it of course that's the point
of collecting any data is to make sure
that we can then allocate resources in
an appropriate way um right now uh the
so and I should step back and mention
that the bill you have in front of you
really is a collaboration it it comes
from the work that was done um with the
AG's office the uh State Department of
Safety State Police and uh some work
with the ACLU and some work with a a
variety of stakeholders who have
interest in this issue so I think it's
very important that we make sure that
we're collecting it and we're doing it
in a timely fashion that is one of the
things that's so interesting when we
think about um collection of data is it
isn't useful if it's old it's better if
we can collect it in a timely fashion so
let me just mention that this would um
require that law enforcement agencies
report bias motivated crimes hate crimes
to the Department of Safety so that it
can then then be made available on its
website uh currently the department of
safety has a very good website some of
it more usable than others but um there
is what is called the theme oriented
public site uh right now the theme
oriented public site includes uh
statistics on drug use and DUI violent
crime and property crime but they are
planning soon to um add three more
themes and that would be sexual assault
domestic violence and bias related
crimes so in order to um have this uh
website up and running and be effective
we need to make sure the data is being
collected and reported in a timely
fashion and that is in fact what SB 315
questions thank you Senator um is there
a definition and statute what what a
bias crime is yes
gonna okay um so in at the bottom of
3:15 you will see that it mentions um
protected characteristics identified in
either RSA 354 B1 or RSA 651 colon 6 uh
r Roman 1 F and in that case um in
says conduct is motivated by race color
religion national origin ancestry sexual
orientation sex gender identity or
disability
51 colon
6 uh Roman 1
F uh substantially motivated to commit
the crime because of hostility toward
the victims religion race Creed sexual
orientation national origin sex or
gender identity and those include
further definitions thank you and as far
as who DET the officer investigating the
crime would be the one who would make
that determination
yes and that's a really good question um
that is determined I believe the FBI
definition and I'm paraphrasing so um
and that is part what um defines this is
uh through objective measures and educ
an investigation a reasonable and
prudent person would believe it to be
so further questions representative um
new
a
little um it kind of gives a little bit
of to understand uh any type of emerging
Trends and things like that uh we end up
trying
tot yes absolutely would be a way of
understanding the trends and a variety
of information would be posted on the
website including clearance of cases and
disposition um and I I appreciate you
bringing up um
at least it I believe it was yesterday
um representative selig uh introduced to
the Judiciary Committee uh her bill
regarding um a study committee on
restorative restorative justice and uh
bias crimes and I think
that that the study committee is going
to need to be looking at data and these
are the kinds of data that we can use to
know whether is it a problem is it an
increasing problem is is it a problem we
need to identify and how best can we
identify you're
welcome representative
sik thank you and thank you senator for
taking my question um so in the language
um line three it references law
enforcement agencies and then it
continues to talk about the law
enforcement agencies will make the
report um don't is the my understanding
is the prosecutor for that area as part
of the law enforcement agency or is that
different um in terms of who's like
would it could I guess my question is
really would it could it be the
prosecutor who ultimately helps make the
determination with the police dep
Department about whether it's a hate
motivated crime versus just a crime of
passion or something I would imagine I
would imagine so but I I think we could
question see no further questions thank
you for your thank you very much for
which thank you Mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee um I'm here
on behalf of the American civil
liberties un uh Union of New Hampshire
my name is Henry Clement toit I'm a
senior staff attorney we are in support
of this legislation as the prime sponsor
said it would help gather the data
necessary to figure out the extent to
which this is a problem how it's
changing where in the state these things
are happening um and mostly I just
wanted to commend the good work of
Senator Chanley the Attorney General's
office and the state police for all of
their efforts on this um I urge the
committee to give this favorable
consideration happy to take any
questions thank you
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
the chair calls um Victor Muzzy from the
state
police thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Victor Muzzy
um Captain in the State Police that
oversees the criminal records unit and
part of that is the UCR subunit within
the criminal records unit um just to
clarify as the senator said we do have
our own State Police website in addition
to that we have the Topps website which
is a thirdparty
hosted website that we utilize to report
crime data and statistics so
historically that has consisted of I'll
call it two areas one area that's kind
of geared towards crime analysts and a
lot of intricate information that's not
really um I can't say user friendly it
is to the audience that it's intended
for but it's it's it's kind of deep
stuff and you got to dig around a lot to
to to understand what you're looking at
and so this this Topps website as we
refer to it is sort of a more user
friendly public site it that will more
readily display information in a way
that's easily more easily digestible and
so pursuant to what the the senator said
we do have um a project on uh the plate
right now to expand that by three
additional themes giving us a total of
six as the senator had had said so I
think it's important to note a couple of
things a um we are collecting this data
right now U it's on a yearly basis not
on a six-month basis um and and that's
part of the current UCR program that we
currently report up to the feds on the
digestability of the way we present that
probably could could stand to to use
some um polishing I'll say and that's
what we intend to do with this project
so um I think Senator you are correct
and I think the definition um as it's
been laid before us because there's some
question right is it about a conviction
is it where where do we make the
determination that a hate crime is
considered that and so it made sense to
me to reference what the FBI uses for
that definition just so there's
consistency and I think we've captured
that in the bill here um which is
basically you know the officer or
someone of of um reasonable
determination to say this seems to be
motivated by by a bias uh just to keep
everything consistent so that that all
made sense to me so just to clarify for
the members we are collecting it um
again and making that available not in
probably the most easily digestible way
but we're we're working on that um and
again this bill I think makes it um more
readily available in a in a in a more
timely F you know manner or fashion I
suppose which is probably a good thing
for this purpose so my intent really as
I think it is right now is to have a
link on our website that points to that
tops website um so that people you know
know where to go and I think that will
satisfy the the bill and will be easy
for us to to implement as we've already
done with the other three themes so um I
think that's all I have to add this
morning so thank you for your time and
I'll take any questions thank you
Captain so on a yearly basis now you
report up to the feds correct
but do you update your data as it in
real time as it comes in and then you
just transmit that to the feds once a
year yeah well I I I think um we
actually do it on a monthly basis um but
we have a statute a state statute that
allows us um I believe until April 1st
the year following to make sure that
those statistics are finalized I suppose
so um we do tend to do it on a monthly
basis that es and flows a little bit
some agencies a little bit more
difficult to get their you know their
data and information compiled um but
it's the intent to do that you know not
once a year but 12 times a year or as
close there too um and and get it
uploaded so I guess the the that was
just a foundational question the the six
months won't be a problem then as far as
Staffing you're getting that in there in
time yeah I don't I don't believe it
will really it's just obviously written
down that we should we should be doing
it more frequently so it will just put
emphasis on the local Department
departments and ours including ours of
course it's it's twofold for us right we
we create some of the statistics but
we're also responsible for it in the
State Police so I think it just puts
more emphasis on on getting those things
um finalized sooner and
reported okay and back to the um
determination piece of
this the officer doing the
investigation would check off whether he
feels or she feels this is in a
reasonable determination that this is a
biased crime
um and that's done there was a question
earlier whether that could be done by
the um by the prosecutor or not that's
done in the field right that's not done
in the court because you could actually
bring an enhanced charge for that
correct that's really what happens is it
might be the crime of criminal mischief
um but there's an enhanced penalty if
it's you know bias motivated and so that
that's how it works so I suppose to
answer that question to the best of my
knowledge it certainly could be the
prosecutor looking at the facts and
circumstances in the case and making a
determination about charging that as a
bias motivated crime or that it may
qualify now as everyone probably is
aware they could make the determination
that although they feel that they can't
prove that so they don't charge it that
way but that doesn't mean for this
purpose in my mind that it still should
be reported as a as a bias motivated
crime there may be some hindrance to
them successfully Prosecuting it as such
but in my mind the agency whether that
involves their prosecutor or their their
Command Staff or whatever you know may
be should be the ones responsible
ultimately as a team to determine
whether or not it it meets the standard
and and should be reported as such so is
the is the data though that you report
is it clear that whether or not a a
charge was actually brought and whether
or not it was Pro uh successfully
prosecuted or it's not at the moment so
we would have to consider how to I guess
adequately capture that between us and
the court um obviously we we we we share
data
um back and forth with the court now so
that's that would be an
additional couple of steps I guess at
the moment our reporting obligation
based upon the federal definition and
guidelines is once that box is checked
so to speak and the determination has
been made at the agency level that it's
a bias motivated crime that's it that's
where it stops we just that
determination has been made it gets
reported that way and there is no real
follow through to determine was it
charged that way was there a conviction
um under that so that would be I guess
some additional reporting considerations
and some communication that would have
to be ironed out in order to do this
effectively um I see what the intent
here is but it's it seems to me the
value of the information gets called
into question if if an initial
determination is made bias and for
example when the person goes to a jury
trial it's found not guilty well then
there was no bias crime because he was
not guilty so therefore the information
skewed and at the local level we want
accurate because we could use it for all
sorts of purposes funding targeted
policing things like that nature so um I
wonder if there's a a way to add a box
or or that's going to take you going
back I mean don't you already follow the
cases through to the end at least as far
as your prosecutions
and well we do I mean the state police
does for our own certainly you know what
I mean not not the locals obviously
but you know what what I might see
happening is you know the court in their
sentencing or in their finding may have
to check their box to say you know what
whatever it may be so that we can close
that Loop a little more effectively
so that's something to consider you know
and again I think the purpose here is to
determine at the at the street level
I'll say you know was this bias
motivated now a thousand things can
happen between investigation and
successful prosecution which can change
the data or change the way that the data
turns out and you know as as I
understand it and see it it really
doesn't matter I mean it does matter
what the outcome is because we want to
know people are being held accountable
to a certain standard
but from an in in instance standpoint
you know really what we want to know is
how many of these things are
occurring um in order to how to you know
adequately address them the outcome is
is
important but then we get into what are
we really grading here are we grading a
successful prosecution are we trying to
determine um how things change over the
course of that prosecution or really
just looking at is this stuff occurring
where is it occurring and what do we
feel might be a reasonable outcome um
whether that's restorative justice or
some other process to reduce it I mean
that's I know I'm adding a bunch of
layers of complexity the issue I'm just
trying to I'm trying to get to the value
of the information and the more accurate
the information more value of what it is
so if it's if it's determinations on the
street level that um it's a bias crime
and then at trial a witness comes
forward and and it turns out that was
all incorrect that information is no
longer valuable other than the fact that
an officer made a determination so it's
it's just maybe something we have to
look at further down the road to make
the information more accurate sure um
representative
Newman thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question yes sir um I don't
know if there's a requirement for the
locals to report hate crimes now or not
but I'd be curious I'd be curious for
what the effect of the six months do you
think you'll get more information less
information how do you think that will
affect what you get now I think we'd get
the same information I just think the
message to them would be that it's
important and it needs to be done more
frequently um I I can't say that it
isn't happening now it may very well be
on a monthly basis when we're we're
expecting these folks to to send us
their files for upload into the
repository for the
FBI um I just think it put puts emphasis
on it to make sure that you know if they
have a long prosecution or a long
investigation or something like that
that you know it it it gets the focus
and attention it needs so I don't I
don't necessarily see anything changing
from that perspective just that it it
puts more emphasis on it to get it get a
determination made in order to report it
you know um more frequently really thank
you representative seig thank you Mr
chair and thank you so much for taking
my question I actually two questions
that are related um the first is
essentially a followup on on chairman
Roy's question about if someone's found
not guilty but it doesn't mean the crime
hasn't still been committed it just
means that that person was found not
guilty being committed that's what I was
trying to say not as quite as eloquently
or curtailed but yes if if I can ask the
second part which is um with with crimes
hate crimes we know that sometimes are
committed by juveniles as well this data
wouldn't extrapolate out juveniles
because it's not talking about who's
being prosecuted or that it just would
indicate the number of crimes is that
correct it's basically you know did this
circumstance set up facts rise to level
of a hate crime it's not we're not
necessarily
tracking on a national level you know
the age of the offender we are you know
certainly because we know who did it and
and who the who the offender was but not
in concert you know what I mean so thank
Muse thank you so one one example I can
think of uh is one that occurred in
Portsmouth where we've had uh swas
stickers um that have been spray painted
on a synagogue so in a case like that uh
I'm not even sure they've actually found
the person who's done it yet so under
this system um that act um the fact that
it was reported that somebody spray
painted a swastika on a synagogue that
would actually be reported as a hate
crime not as uh
uh uh uh criminal mischief or vandalism
or something like that well it would it
just has a hate crime element to it you
know what I mean the the the criminal
violation is just that criminal mischief
but it's motivated by a bias which is
which is the determination that could be
made you know almost immediately I would
presume upon re receiving that call or
that investigation so and that's I guess
the distinction we're trying to make
here is certainly in my mind that would
be a pretty clear convincing and quickly
evident
um bias motivated crime and should be
reported as such the fact that no
offenders have been located or
determined yet is is another piece to
that
but follow
up thank you and and what is what in
your mind is the value of
collecting this data um even if we never
find the offender and even if these uh
prosecuted I think education much like
has been mentioned you know um I I I
don't know who these offenders are
certainly it could have been anybody I
suppose but you know the the the
juvenile um Talk has come up and and I I
think there was some testimony that I
overheard yesterday online um and you
know I I I think certainly the juveniles
that have committed this type of offense
are looking for some rise out of folks
and is it true truly motivated by a bias
I I don't know I I would tend to think
that you know probably the juveniles in
some cases have heard that this gets a
rise out of people and gets their
attention in things and so I I think the
value in it is certainly um where these
things are occurring um who the
offenders are I think will help us
understand whether it's an educational
issue whether it's a punishment issue
whether it's um
that there's may be some other Arena we
had not considered in both law making
and education relative to the to topic
so I I think it does have some value um
the real trouble is you know again
determining in some instances like this
one you know was it truly bias motivated
or was it just to get attention you know
or or some other
Factor but it will at least help us
start to understand you
know where and why hopefully but maybe
you broken
[Music]
yeah
stand do you think in a way that would
in
did in the restorative
justice
conviction is your question do you think
that the the prosecutors would push for
convictions versus allowing a plea
because of that would make the data
different I'm asking about yes I'm not
I'm not giv you know assuming
badt what I'm saying is just human
nature you believe that um this is
something that we need to pay attention
to and a conviction is what would get
the information out there rep do you
think that just naturally that would
create an incentive for um for
har I suppose if we change the standard
to be conviction related yes and that
that may very well be why it's not
conviction related it's simply uh
investigation related or at that level
so um I again I think it's important
maybe to look at conviction rates or
data but certainly don't want to
incentivize that to to skew
anything and to be clear for based on
the line of questions on hearing I
wasn't suggesting that that would be the
requirement I was suggesting that would
be an additional data point that would
be important um further
there we go now we're on chair Roy
members of the House criminal justice
and Public Safety Committee my name is
Shawn lock I'm a senior Assistant
Attorney General and director of the
Attorney General civil rights unit I'm
here on behalf of the Attorney General's
office to lend support to Senate Bill
315 I'd prepared comments but in
listening to the questions the benefit
of going last is I think I'll start with
the questions that have come up over
this past half hour or so um so I want
to talk a little bit about the process
what happens when a hate crime is
charged how is a hate crime char charged
so in New Hampshire any offense can
become a hate crime it is a sentencing
enhancement so it's something that gets
added on it's an element in addition to
the underlying criminal offense that has
to be proven Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
for a person to be convicted of a hate
crime there's no separate hate crime
kind of charge that gets brought it's
added on um that means that the
prosecutor has to show as was kind of
said at the beginning that the criminal
offense was substantially motivated by
hostility towards the victims protect
what I call protected characteristics so
race religion sexual orientation gender
identity and
others if that is done the person is
then and the jury convicts the person
and agrees uh they find them guilty of
the hate Mo and crime enhanced criminal
offense it increases the criminal
penalty that the person may face for
misdemeanors it rises to two to five
years for most felonies 10 to 30 and for
felonies like murder and manslaughter it
increases the penalty
further but that can't occur if police
aren't necessarily kind of being
encouraged to identify hate motivated
conduct when it happens that's the
important element that's the important
element in emphasizing the collection of
this data is to kind of allow and
encourage law enforcement to look for
and and look for that hate motivation if
and when it is present if and when it is
being alleged by a victim and you know
kind of coming back to some of my
prepared comments the timely publication
of this data enables my office wait go
back to the beginning here 5 years ago
our office issued protocols to Aid law
enforcement and identifying
investigating and Reporting hate crimes
and Civil Rights Act violations it's a
civil statute that I primarily enforce
but works similar to a hate crime charge
um we have since been training all new
police officers with a two-hour block of
instruction on how to identify potential
hate motivated acts and one goal in
doing that was to improve reporting of
hate crimes through the nber system
which is the national incident-based
Reporting System that's used by State
Police and others to capture this data
and refer refer it up to the FBI um SB
315 takes that goal
further
it reemphasizes the importance of
reporting but also sets additional
standards guidance for law enforcement
before this you know it wasn't
necessarily clear when an in I think
that's some of the conversation we've
had here today when something has to be
reported as a hate crime is it after a
person has been convicted is it when it
is suspected by the officer for the
purposes of gathering that initial crime
data you know we suggested my office
suggested that it should be based on
Reasonable Suspicion which is when the
officer develops a suspicion that this
could be and it doesn't have to be the
investigating officer it could be up the
line so it could be a detective looking
at this case it could be the prosecutor
when the case is referred to them that
develops a suspicion that this could be
a hate motivated act that's when it
needs to that data needs to be updated
so it can be captured correctly if at
some point that suspicion is completely
dispelled there's no evidence you know
what what was initially believed to be a
hate crime turns out that it was not the
case that data could be updated as well
but setting that
standard has benefits it ensures that
hate crimes are being identified and
those conversations about whether or not
this person should be charged with a
hate crime is being is is occurring it
encourages law enforcement and the way I
often describe it when I'm training law
enforcement is that when there's
suspicion of a hate crime you're not
doing a misdemeanor investigation
anymore you're doing a felony level
investigation because that person is
facing felony level penalties including
significant periods of incarceration so
you have to change how you're
approaching these cases to make sure
that it is is you know no stone unturned
because you're charging someone with a
significant offense you want to make
sure you have all the evidence to secure
that conviction but you also want to
make sure if there is evidence that says
this person should not be charged in a
certain way that you've done that as
well there's also value even where a
suspect isn't identified because it
helps identify trends that affect
communities across the state and
resources can be directed to those
communities to support them to support
those you know support the immediate
victims but also those who
live look worship love like those
victims because hate crimes don't occur
in isolation they don't occur you know
they are designed they message crimes
designed to do more and affect people
beyond the immediate victim of the
incident they're designed to send
messages to the entire community of
people who are like that person to send
the message that you are unsafe here
you're unwelcome here and it has that
impact you know we receive when hate
crimes do occur in the Hampshire or when
they are suspected to have occur heard
people across entire communities reach
out asking what's going on with this
case what's happened here what can I do
to help um but also you know am I safe
here is this somewhere where like if
something happens to me are police going
to respond appropriately are they going
to be available so the having this data
and understanding where resources need
to be directed is valuable in and of
itself even if it doesn't lead to hate
crime convictions because maybe the
evidence can't prove that case Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt maybe you know the
evidence you know the there's a plea
that is more kind of successful maybe
there's a call for restorative justice
because that is the appropriate response
in that circumstance you know that may
be the case in those circumstances but
those victims and those communities
affected still need resources and
support so there is value even in
collecting the data even short of when
it leads to
convictions additionally the timely
publication of this data will enable my
office to cross check our reports and
referrals that we received from law
enforcement to make sure that you know
where people have reported potential
hate crimes or Civil Rights Act
violations to us we can make sure that
gets reported and gets captured in state
police's data but also where we're
seeing data in State Police from
agencies or communities that haven't
reported things to us we can follow up
with them to understand what's going on
in those communities why was this not
reported to us and one kind of final
note on that is you know with this bill
in mind with the fact that our protocols
have been issued and been promulgated
and been out there for over five year or
almost 5 years now we are looking at how
to engage re-engaging with law
enforcement engaging with prosecutors
engaging with the communities affected
to see what more can where can we take
this further whether it is I think some
their points of tracking information
through from when it's reported as a
hate crime through to the conviction to
understand where might there be
hindrances to kind of taking that case
sometimes it's plea bargaining sometimes
it's a failure to secure a conviction
sometimes it's a failure to identify a
suspect but understanding kind of what
is leading to the dis what might cause
the disparity between what is reported
in this data and what ultimately results
in convictions at the end of a trial so
there's you know more to be done in
terms of gathering this data but without
this data we can't have those later
conversations because we don't even know
where we're beginning to figure out
where these cases end and so with all of
that in mind we would ask that you vote
ought to pass on SB 315 and I'm happy to
scite in part of your testimony you said
when you were training law enforcement
and there's an element
of Hate in Your crime that it's now
they're doing a felony investigation is
a misdemeanor get promoted to a felony
because of hate the element of hate it
doesn't become a felony I tell them to
treat it like a felony investigation
because the penalties the person faces
are like felony level penalties so uh
class B felony is a three and a half a
potential three and a half to sevene
period of incarceration a hate crime
enhanced misdemeanor is a two to five
year potential two to fiveyear period
That's why
yeah representative here at
G thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm not sure if this
question is for you if it should have
been for um Captain Muzzy fuzzy yes but
um I received some data that gave hate
crime information for 2022 and I think
he mentioned that April is the cut off
for you know giving that data to
whomever okay for the federals and so
for 20123 is that data available now so
that would be a question for Captain
Muzzy but um I
know the FBI I think recently released
and compiled with the data that's
provided by jurisdictions across the
country it's 2022 data so there is a lag
in the FBI certainly releasing the data
I don't know if the state police's kind
not representative s thank you and thank
you for taking my question attorney um
you mentioned one use of the data could
be potentially directing resources to an
area so in the case where representative
Muse talked about the synagogue and
Portsmouth being um you know having
swastikas done and that one was actually
they caught the person but they have not
yet caught the person who smashed the
windows the other day um would it mean
something like being able to direct
additional Financial Resources for
additional security or other measures to
protect against those things so it could
be it can Bean numerous things so some
of it could be you know when it comes to
houses of Warship I know that the
department of safety I think it's
division of Homeland Security and
emergency planning but they have
resources for houses of Warship um where
necessary to improve security or even to
do security walkthroughs and we've
encouraged when we've met with all
different communities particularly
communities of Faith you know to
encourage engage with your local police
departments to do walkthroughs and
security trainings in your in your
building because if anything were to
happen in that church synagogue Temple
of any sort mosque um they local police
knowing where things are knowing where
the doors are knowing where the hallways
are where people could hide that's value
that they won't otherwise have I mean I
know in some communities that the houses
of worship even uploaded blueprints to
local police department so they know the
layout of the space so kind of having
that information can help us Foster
those relationships can help direct
where you know available resources um
Financial Resources to victims uh
certainly depending on the nature of the
crime those victims Also may be eligible
to apply for assistance from our victims
Compensation Program so they could seek
uh recovery of costs for you know
medical care or any other treatment that
they may need or any other loss they may
have suffered as a result of the
criminal act so yes uh Financial
Resources is one kind of opportunity but
also you know doing Outreach kind of
learning what the community's needs are
learning you know maybe if there are
particular communities targeted maybe
you know helping to Foster programs and
opportunities to kind of bring people
together for who have been victims of
hate crimes and provide support directly
to those individuals in the same way we
do for victims of sexual assault and
domestic violence ensuring that those
individuals have kind of appropriate
well no further questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony thank you
anyone else wishing to testify in this
bill who hasn't testified seeing none I
hereby close public
hearing
and
what's I open the public hearing on
House Bill 321
and invite the sponsor to introduce the
know morning Mr President
good morning members of the committee Mr
chair um for the record Jeb Bradley from
District 3 and wolfboro so Senator abbis
um was not able to be here today and
asked me to introduce this bill which
the Senate passed um and it is part of
our um bail reform package and was
included um in the past and bail reform
measures that I sponsored it does a
couple of things um right now there is a
rebuttable presumption that if
somebody um does
not show up for their court appearance
that they can be detained but it's not
mandatory and that rebuttable
presumption comes within um three times
being a no-show in 5 years and so CTI
Bill 321 would change that to three
times in five years and then require be
um because there have been three
no-shows that the person shall be
detained that is um the first section of
the bill lines 3 through
8 uh lines 9 through 12 um if a person
is detained pursuant to subsection a
that person would have an opportunity at
a bail hearing um that that person can
submit evidence that the court would um
decide whether the person has rebutted
the presumption and that release would
not reasonably assure the appearance of
the person as required so this is part
of our ongoing attempt to um fix
the issues that we have with our Bale
statutes um the Senate has passed this
provision several times um it got hung
up in a committee of conference I
believe it was in
2022 and at that point um Senator abbis
and Senator Susi who are the sponsors of
Senate bills on bail decided to split um
the two Provisions that we've been
considering uh the one provision that
this committee has done a lot of good
work on on um is the list of crimes for
which you would have to see a judge um
in order to um be granted bail so I I
just want to say thank you to all of you
for the work that you've done I think
the Senate looks forward to um working
with you as we work through that process
there'll probably be a few questions but
that's okay um but this is part two of
the efforts
to ensure that our bail system is
adhered to and that we don't have a
revolving door in New Hampshire so I
commend it to you and again um you know
I want to thank all of you for the work
that you've done representative Roy
you've done Yan's effort but so is the
so is the committee and we look forward
to working with you on um the other
bills that you have before
you thank you senator um also as part of
the the package that we sent out that we
worked on over the summer we we already
we addressed this as well too so it's
going to be a we have a we certainly
have a curse of a number of riches to
work from um from all of our work any
any questions for
Senator seeing none thank you thank
you anyone else wishing to testify on
Senate Bill 321 who hasn't seing none I
hereby Clos public heing and we will
than
I
at
e
okay we're opening the um public hearing
on Senate Bill 424
and I recognize Senator Whitley oh there
you
are thank you Mr chair good morning
members of the committee um uh for the
record my name is Becky Whitley I'm
honored to represent New Hampshire
Senate District 15 which includes the
wonderful communities of conquered Bo
and hopkington today I'm honored to
introduce to you Senate Bill
424 this bill was de uh developed in
close collaboration with the Department
of Corrections and it merely refines
existing law by establishing a clear
framework for parole eligibility as
intended by the legislature the law as
it is currently written is vague and
does not provide probation parole
officers with legal
Direction on how to consistently
consider parole EAS for a reduction of
their maximum sentence so additionally
individuals under administrative
supervision are only seen once per year
and this bill creates an annual audit
system an an annual audit requirement
for those cases so I um also want to put
this in context so I was the chair and
um two of the members uh of the
committee were on this committee as well
uh two years ago this uh legislature
created Senate Bill five or passed
Senate Bill 251 which created a
committee to look at the adult parole
system it was an incredibly productive
committee we met many many times over
the summer and the fall hearing from
everyone involved in the system um folks
who were impacted folks who run the
system folks who are are related to the
system and we came up with a pretty
comprehensive report so in its report um
the sp251 committee recommended the
development of clear and concise policy
language and parole guidelines to
provide greater structure when weighing
or evaluating the factors associated
with the decision to Grant or deny
parole so um I want I I'm happy to take
any technical questions um I will try to
but certainly the Department of
Corrections is here and they can you
know answer the more detailed questions
but we're not
changing polic we're not changing policy
we're just taking existing practice is
my understanding and making it clear in
the statute I think this is good for the
the folks who run the parole system and
the folks who impacted by it so thank
you very much for your consideration of
this bill um and I am happy to take any
questions
questions seeing none thank you oh thank
good morning members of the
committee uh the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections is in support
of Senate Bill
424 thank you I appreciate you allowing
me to speak today on this Senate Bill
relative to the reduction of Maximum
sentence while on parole my name is
Jeffrey white I'm the director of field
services for the New Hampshire
Department of
Corrections and I've been there for
about a year and a half now and uh it's
been it's been great so far really
appreciate the support we have the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections is
pleased pleas to support the bill and
would like to thank Senator Whitley and
the Bill's co-sponsors for its
introduction the bill makes several
changes to the law that the department
FS will positively impact the probation
parole system first this bill refines
existing law by establishing clear
framework for parole eligibility
specifically with the reduction of
Maximum as intended by the
legislature the law as it is currently
written is vague and does not provide
the probation parole officers with legal
Direction on how to consistently
consider Parolees for reduction of their
m maximum sentence this bill has the
potential to incentivize individuals on
parole by adding additional factors for
parole board to consider when making the
decision on whether to Grant someone a
reduction of their maximum
sentence by adding factors such as
employment engagement with treatment
compliance with parole conditions and
others it encourages parole e to engage
in productive behavior and
rehabilitative treatment in order to
lessen their time on
supervision finally this bill creates an
annual audit which Senator Whitley had
just referred to requirement for the
probation PE officers to complete for
individuals who are on administrative
supervision with the purpose of
presenting qualified candidates to the
adult parole board for reduction of
their maximum
sentences the department currently has
approximately 455 individuals on
administrative
supervision pursuant to RSA 504 a15
probation and Parolees who have
completed a period of active supervision
9 months for a misdemeanor offense on
probation 12 months for a felony
probation offense or 18 months on parole
may be placed on administrative
supervision status if they're not
assessed as high- risk and have no
adjudicated
violations and they're not on uh placed
on parole or probation for a felony
listed under tier 2 or tier three sex
offense under RSA 651 B1 Roman numeral 9
and 10 pries placed on administrative
supervision are required to report
annually and must notify their probation
paral officer of any new arrest change
in address or plans to relocate out of
state they also face potential
reclassification of their supervision
level for any new arrest conviction or
significant non-compliance with their
probation or parole conditions by adding
the annual audit requirement for the
probation parole office to review the
individual under administrative
supervision this has the potential to
increase the number of deserving
individuals appearing before the Adult
Parole Board to have their maximum
sentence reduced this in turn will
decrease the case loads of the probation
PR officers allowing them to dedicate
essential time and resources to those
individuals on supervision who need it
the
most thank you again for the opportunity
to speak in support of Senate Bill 424
I'm happy to take any questions that you
may
have thank you could you um could you
take give us a hypothetical rly and just
kind of walk us through how this would
apply so someone um is incarcerated for
whatever they become eligible for in our
granted parole that's when this new
legislation would come into effect
correct so if you were sentenced to uh
say two and a half to five years in the
state prison yeah at the two and a half
year mark you're eligible for parole you
go in front of the parole board say your
peace and hopefully granted parole now
you're on Community Supervision which is
being supervised by approbation parole
officer in the community when that
happens as long as uh if it's a felony
level offense if they're on supervision
for 18 months and they're basically low
not really a high need person that needs
to be supervised on a daily basis a
weekly basis or po you know even a
monthly basis they could get reduced
down to administrative status as long as
they're rated as a low uh which like I
said is a real low need we we trust the
fact they're doing the right thing
they're gainfully employed they have
family support they're not housing
challenged uh they have food they
they're not hanging around with the
people that they were potentially no
substance use issues or they're dealing
with treatment for it uh mental health
issues are being addressed so once
you've been on
administrative uh supervision for about
18 months that's when we'd like to look
at somebody and say okay this person's
doing all the right things how do we
reward them
how can we help them better themselves
and let them continue on the right path
which is our goal Rehabilitation and
getting people back to society to being
productive so at that 18-month Mark we
want to be able to look at and say okay
this person deserves a reduction in
their maximum sentence would be that
five years because you're on supervision
from that you know two and a half year
mark to five years so two and a half
more years on supervision as a perole Le
if we see they're doing well for a year
and a half well then we we can knock
some of that time off and say all right
we've done our job we've helped
rehabilitate this person we've given
them the guidance and the tools to be
productive now let's let them free to
see if they continue on that path okay
so after a successful period on
administrative um parole yeah then this
would contemplate looking at okay so we
can take up to a third of your remaining
Paro time correct and you're you're all
wrapped up you're good to go and this
statute is giving guidelines to both the
parole officer and the parole board as
to what they should consider when
they're considering giving that onethird
yes it it gives you the time time
periods and it also gives you the amount
that they can reduce okay great um any
questions representative here gather
thank you chair um director white um how
many people did you say are eligible now
400 and something there's approximately
455 on administrative supervision
currently okay thank you
other
questions um correct me if I'm wrong so
many of our our benefits and um even
things that um would help someone clear
their record there's a time period that
tolls and and that doesn't start to toll
until the sentence is complete and part
of that is their parle of probation so
the earlier they get that done the
sooner they can qualify for certain
things is that correct that is correct
once once they've wrapped up their
sentence then the time starts
before they can consider being seeking
out an En helment to remove their record
okay so that's a reward in of itself is
that you can not only are you you don't
have to come see me once a year um you
also can begin the process of getting
your record cleaned yes a little bit
earlier absolutely okay thank you um so
you no further questions thank you very
much thank you sir thank you anyone else
wishing to testify in this bill who has
not testified seeing none hereby close
11:
e
we are opening the public
hearing on where is it 426 Senate Bill
426 and I invite who do we got
Bill let me turn on the mic here I'm
Senator Bill Ganon I represent District
23 a beautiful area in Sandown to seab
Brook in commonly known in my area as
the wine region come on down to sand
down we have great wines at know um
that's my little plug it's supposed to
be funny um tough tough crowd so this
bill was um I brought it on behalf of
the police Chiefs and the way reason we
bought it it brought it Forward is we're
concerned with impaired driving on the
roads um especially poly use driving but
I won't get into that too much mix of
alcohol and drugs at the same time but
deaths are up accidents are up they even
found one guy a couple months ago in 93
two in the morning passed out in his car
in the middle of the road so I'm
concerned with the safety of all of us I
have four kids I want them safe out
there and I want your kids safe out
there surrounding states have done this
type of law Massachusetts vermod
California Colorado Illinois Washington
Washington State DC amongst others so
the idea is it's sort of like a wingspan
rule um which is a common idea in law
that you try to keep everything as far
away from the driver in his wingspan as
possible possible it's more used with
guns and other stuff but it's the same
concept so we have if we I've been told
for years and years everyone wanted to
treat marijuana medicinal or whatever
the same as alcohol so we won't talk
about medicinal at the moment we'll get
to that in the second but if you have a
container of alcohol you can't have it
sitting next to you when you're driving
in the car you have to have it as far
away as possible so ideally if you've
opened a container of gummies or
whatever you have any type of marijuana
ideally you'd place it in your trunk uh
you might have a pickup truck you can't
do that so we want you to place it again
as far as possible under the back seat
in the glove compartment uh if you only
had a cab truck it would probably be
under the passenger seat or in the glove
compartment but again trying to keep it
Out Of Reach of the driver same idea as
alcohol an open bottle you keep it as
far away certainly you don't have it
next to in the seat um so we were
concerned and um you guys have 20 people
we only have a few in our committee so
there was concern now with people having
therapeutic Cannabis cards how should we
treat them because it's now a medicine
it was brought so we did the an
amendment to say if you have a cannabis
card we would try to treat that like a
prescription drug so that's a little
gray area that I don't think we handled
it quite well in our Amendment we have
an amendment and the idea was to treat
that like a drug you could have the open
container because if you an opioid
prescription and you took something
um so it's a little weak because then
you're going to have Treat marijuana
differently in two two situations but we
really couldn't figure a better way
around it before we got out of the
committee so the best we could do was
this amendment uh to keep both sides
happy it did go through I believe 50 and
committee and I think it went fairly
well through the Senate not sure if it
was unanimous or not but again so that
would be the only area if you guys had
better thoughts than we did as to
amending it for someone with a
prescription cannabis card because again
I don't want them really taking the
gummies either while they're driving so
it's sort of a I saw the flaw especially
last night when I was looking at this
I'm like oh we didn't really do but
that's why we have you guys to clean up
our small little arrows and um that is
about it and um I look forward to any
questions and I don't know if law
enforcement's going to testify after us
but they may
be thank you Senator was there any
thought thought given to just treating
it exactly the same as alcohol I've I've
brought this for Bill forward before and
it was always exactly the same as
alcohol because I now it's going to have
Pro there's potential problems with
something had you know you had to open
container gummies and you're like oh no
that's my medicine I take that
for um but it still can you know raise
your THC level and make you high so
again it's a safety concern but last
minute we didn't see a better way of
doing it um it the therapeutic cannabis
board came forward and they brought to a
couple people's attention that we were
treating this knot as a medicine if you
had a therapeutic card um in years past
again it's two or three times has come
here before just straight out treat it
like a you know a open container of
alcohol Keep It Out Of Reach as far as
possible whatever part of the vehicle
that would
be and with I was hoping law enforcement
was going to testify but with regard to
the law enforcement concern that they
wanted you to bring this
um what is it they're find they're
finding obviously what the guy passed
out that was probably opioids but what
is there concern that people are smoking
and driving is that a lot more so like
two out of three accidents especially
it's even higher I believe in um in
crashes um it's about 66% are poly use
is now the common thing you know you're
drinking and you're smoking they're
finding that as one of the most common
but I mean you could just be drunk and
impaired and you could just be stoned
and impaired but um po use seems to be a
very big problem at the moment um so at
the accident scenes that's what's
they're find two out of three is a poly
use and um which I understand because as
an attorney I've always it's bothered me
that if you're drunk we can get you with
the
0.08 and again get you means I want the
roads to be safe it doesn't mean that
I'm after anyone for us and um I
personally don't like either one too
much but um um again I've probably been
at accident scenes too many times um
what was your question more um so so yes
so law enforcement has come to me and um
uh commissioner Edwards testified in the
Senate on it I had a lot of law
enforcement testify that I'm sorry they
got I used up all their time I guess um
but yeah the accidents are going up
they're swapping people and um we had
someone in one of your committees last
year who said they were using gummies
while they I believe it was last year
while they were Al and um it just people
don't take it serious enough I don't
mind what you do recreational at home or
if you have a um if you have a condition
you got a medical card that's great but
you can't do it when you're driving um
AC are up and again it's the police have
reported about 66% increase uh in usage
and they're having problems so we just
want the roads to be safe okay um any
further questions for Sen yeah
representative n
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question thank you I'm curious
about um you know with alcohol it's very
clear how it would be a sealed bottle um
but how would we ensure that you know
just in the ways that I've seen um you
know the purchase of marijuana if it's
uh how do you how do you ensure I mean
is there is it sealed and then you would
be able to tell if the seal was
broken again so I probably have less
familiarity with the packaging than I
should um talking about so um I I don't
really know what the pedge so if you had
ideally You' put you had an open
container of anything um a bag of
gummies you'd put it in the trunk um you
don't have a trunk put it under the back
seat Senator abis was concerned then
well geez my kids might be in the back
seat and you're putting it um so there
are always concerns but which just the
furthest point away from you is is our
ideal thing glove compartments everyone
seems to have one so if it's there it's
not so hard for you to get when you're
getting out of the car but it would be
pretty hard to get to if you wanted to
get them while you're using them okay
thank you um our our thought is glove
box is like a nice safe area if you
don't have a truck trunk can I follow up
really quickly um so and I understand
that that makes sense to me for it to be
Out Of Reach um absolutely but it does
include the language um the same
language as um alcohol which would be
that it needs to be in a a sealed
container and and that would be um
something that makes the difference in
here and I think that that might not
make make sense in the in the case of
marijuana um can you explain the
packaging to me more so here we got our
bottle right we got a cap on you don't
want that sitting next to you you want
it at least if you had that open whiskey
bottle have it under the back seat so
officer pulls you over he knows at least
you don't have it there and they'll say
have you been drinking you might say I
have a bottle that's under the back seat
what is the packaging like with well
gummies is it ziplock I'm not familiar
I'm sorry there's no law that says you
have to keep in original packaging so
like with prescription drugs I believe
there's a federal law I'm not sure if
New Hampshire statute mirrors it that
you're supposed to keep in the original
drug with the prescription on it since
this is illegal Fe federally that
doesn't apply so someone could get a
package with a seal open it and just
take a couple put it in a baggie or
whatever they want so it's really
difficult to focus on the packaging as
much as the wingspan as you discussed
sure okay thank you claring yes I
appreciate that thank you Newman no so I
I'm relying on you maybe to tweak Newman
sailing thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I I know like
when I've been prescribed medication for
my doctor after posts surgery you know
it always comes with the label saying do
not drive while using do we have um is
there anything with with medical
marijuana you may not know the answer to
this but that would have a similar type
of warning label like this is it is not
recommended to drive while using this
product not sure you guys may know more
than I I think when you get the card
they may may emphasize that but I'm not
sure um I see representative M but first
representative
Murray okay she WS off representative um
M thank you I I just want to verify I
see that the the Senate did amend the
bill uh the original bill um and I think
the part that was amended is uh right up
front uh where it says the word
marijuana is used in this used as used
in this section she have the same
meaning uh as defined in RSA 38 B and
shall not include therapeutic cannabis
so am I understanding you are correct
I'm understanding that this doesn't the
therapeutic cannabis would not be
included under the scope we would not
treat yeah it was so okay uh Senator
Whitley and the head of the therapeutic
cannabis came up with this language that
was acceptable to the majority so okay I
negotiation see no further questions
thank you Senator thank you very much
have a great day we'll see what we can
do with this um chair calls
Howard thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee members for having me today my
name is representative Heath Howard I
represent straford 4 which is the towns
of straford and barington uh as of right
now I'm neutral on this legislation uh I
support the intent I think that the
intent is uh good because we shouldn't
have people impaired while they're
operating motor vehicle uh however I do
have some worries about some of the
specifics in the language uh especially
as it relates to the original container
in The Unbroken seal uh especially if
you know somebody is going to uh uh
somewhere else outside of their original
private property
so if somebody owns say two homes and
they're transporting uh their
therapeutic cannabis uh for instance up
from that sing that first home up to
that second home uh they could not
potentially have the original container
with an unbroken seal and so I think
that that could pose a potential risk uh
for people being uh
unintentionally uh charged with
something that they were not necessarily
intending on
uh doing in the first place when they
may have been trying to follow the law
as closely as they could uh when it
comes to uh representative selig
question about uh whether or not there
are labels on uh the therapeutic
cannabis products there are there are
warnings saying that you should not
operate a motor vehicle uh I believe
that there are a few others I don't have
uh a the warning label on me uh at the
current moment but I I could definitely
get you some additional information
about that if you'd like more uh I can
contact you after the committee uh but
that being said uh there I think needs
to be a little bit more of a broader uh
language to kind of generalize things
that still kind of shows that the driver
is
intending uh on trying to keep the
Cannabis products as far away as uh from
them as possible uh I'm open to any
man thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um this is concerning
your issue about it being the
partially uh secure open container maybe
in different packaging and I might be
wrong but the way I read this is it says
securely capped partially filled
containers of marijuana or marijuana any
other form of unsealed packaging shall
be stored or transported in the trunk of
the motor vehicle I think that satisfies
your concern with that yes but uh as we
had heard
uh not necessarily every vehicle has uh
a a a trunk uh if somebody has a truck
for instance uh putting it in the bed
their truck is not necessarily the most
feasible option uh especially if they
have a sing glove box too doesn't it uh
yeah yeah if I just follow up and that
does say that if you don't have a trunk
or whatever you can wherever is the
least accessible to the driver is a
place you should keep it so I yes if I
interpret this correctly I think that's
satisfies your concerns with uh with the
bill yeah I I I just I'm a bit wary of
the specific language and how we need to
go about this just a little bit more
generally rather than kind of referring
to specifics about where the driver
should be placing it and just kind of
stating that it should not be within
their
reach thank you thank you for your
testimony anyone else anyone else
wishing to testify on this bill who has
not did you have a question oh represent
no okay okay um see no one I hereby
hearing
e
that I open the public hearing on Senate
Bill 653 and I recognize Senor Ganon to
introduce this Bill thank you very much
Mr chairman uh thank you all for having
me today I'm Senator Bill Ganon I rip
I'm from Sandown again from the wine
District of New Hampshire spanning from
Seabrook to Chester but not forgetting
Sandown um I come today before you I'll
tell you why we got here um I go to a
lot of town fairs in the summer um you
guys all probably do door knocking and
stuff but Town Fair is one of my big
things and the last two years every body
who's come to my booth um two out of
three it's immigration they want to talk
about the open border policy um number
two is um is the economy but number one
seems to always be immigration more and
more so lately um so my constituents
have come to me from pretty much all 12
towns and they've said to me you know
the federal government's not doing
anything um as a matter of fact they
feel that um we have no border at all at
the moment
and that we're suffering the effects as
we've seen in Massachusetts where
they're now housing people uh right near
where my daughter lives at the Reggie
Lewis Center they've entered out their
main facility that the community uses um
for senior work for tons of stuff they
do at that Reggie Lewis Center and it's
full of immigrants now in fact the
governor of Massachusetts went so far as
to say there is no more room we need
people to volunteer and start taking
people in um it comes very close to New
Hampshire Senator abbis um his community
um down at the methan border uh I
believe it's a Ramada in an old Inn they
took over the whole thing so one half
mile from our border now and the problem
is not the people themselves I'm sure
most of them are looking for a better
life just like all our grandparents and
great grandparents were and they're here
to raise their families and live an
American Dream unfortunately they're not
being vetted and so mixed in with those
as homeland security has said are
hundreds of they've people on the
terrorist watch list we know people are
being coyotes bringing people in it's
bringing un enough fentanyl to kill us
all in the whole country is coming
through the southern border so it's a
problem that's made every state a border
state um according to the committee on
homeland security it costs approximately
481 billion dollars per year to feed
clothes house educate all the expenses
um associated with the 10 or so million
people have come in in the last 3 to
four years and again our main problem is
they're not being properly vetted so we
do not know who's in the community so
who would that be that would be people
like um we had the man in Rye who was a
mass murderer from Brazil who had
executed uh 12 people in Brazil but he
was living and working amongst us
driving from miramac every day working
to his painting job in Ry it also
includes people like in do we had an
arms dealer um living in plain sight and
um he had come over illegally we had
we've had rapists we've had coyotes on
the Canadian
border it tends to be a magnet for
problems and again we have watched our
other states you were watching every
night if you turn on the TV we're
watching activities of the bad and I
admit it's probably not representative
of the crowd but we are seeing we just
can't handle this flow we could handle a
much smaller flow of illegal immigrants
but um it's a problem so this bill
focuses on a very small area but that's
why we're doing it that's why we're
brought the bill we don't want New
Hampshire to become like Massachusetts
New York and these other states where
the governors their Mayors are saying we
can't handle this we can't handle the
cost we can't handle the security and um
if we allow a sanctuary City I know
we're a local we'd like to think we're a
local control State uh which we're not
but if the town of Lebanon which has a
welcoming ordinance which anyone else uh
by whatever term you want to use it it
is a sanctuary city ordinance um as does
the town of Hanover as do several others
and so just because you Ed the word
welcoming the problem I have with these
ordinances is that they tell the police
officer in the department they shall not
um cooperate with the federal
authorities at all they shall not
disclose information regarding
citizenship or immigration status they
won't let it not to allow anyone into
the police facilities to interrogate
they're not supposed to even make the
phone call if they do a police officer
thinks that's in the public safety they
risk being fired um and sanctioned under
these welcoming ordinances so what we're
asking people to do if a police officer
is pulling someone over say they were
pulling a DUI over and the person either
tells them or it comes to their
knowledge that the person is not here
legally we want them to and then they
find out there's a detainer notice that
comes up on their screen says detainer
wanted by Ice Homeland Security we're
not asking them to do much we're asking
them to make a phone call it's uh going
to cost 10 or 15 cents I'll hand them
the time or quarter if they need it but
it that's all it is and they're going to
call Homeland and say is this a bad
ombre is this someone we need to deport
if it is we're not we're not asking the
police to go enforce federal laws that
is not at all what we're asking we're
telling them can you cooperate these
towns and these two ordinances do not
cooperate with the federal government in
the detainer notice so if there's a
detainer notice they make the phone
call it's a DI Minimus cost at Best they
were they hadn't gone out we're not
hunting anyone down it's if they find
out in the middle of an arrest that the
person is wanted by one of the federal
agencies make the phone call and if they
say it's no one we're interested in
they're most a lot of the time they're
going to say it's an inconsequential
person there's no risk at all and they
will probably just release that person
if they say no that's the next to 911
terrorists we have him on a watch list
he snuck over the Border we have
pictures of him then they they have the
option then to come pick them up the
detainer not they can only hold the
person for 24 hours so there would have
to be a federal detainer notice that was
issued um Homeland ice they have to have
probable cause to believe this person is
subject to Federal prosecution
so the other part would be that
maybe people argue that it's going to be
a big expense what if we have to house
them for the 24-hour period actually
there's a federal facility in Dover um I
talked to the governor's security guards
I was asking about this I said your
state Troopers and they said oh in the
past what we've done is we just dropped
them off and over um and then we were
done with it so the costs are very small
a brief detention you're probably
already detaining them on the state
charge anyways so we don't feel it's a
burden on the police we're not forcing
them to do anything big um they did have
uh some of the Cities again we're we
have two different worlds in some ways
because my suburbs have probably
different feelings than the cities uh
the city of Manchester and some of we'll
just say the more blue leaning cities
have signed they signed and said they're
against this bill but then I've talked
to some of them and I got the Manchester
Police Department to give me their
operating procedure and their operating
procedure says that they will cooperate
with federal agencies and they're not
bed by this um so if they follow their
operating procedures their procedures
say cooperate with the federal
government so was it political in this
sheet that they come up with 12 towns
I'll talk to my uh I've talked to a lot
of people in law enforcement in my area
be they local they're mostly local
police Chiefs and they say they have
done this my own Chief and Sandown said
over the last 20 years he's had three or
four stops he's called ice or Homeland
once or twice they've come and picked
the person up there was no major expense
to him or my town
and uh I I didn't want to read you my
testimony that it didn't the Senate so
it's just been going off the top of my
head here so I should probably slow down
and um again it's it's the safety is the
public safety is our biggest issue if
they were vetted and we had a smaller
crowd coming in it would be one thing
but we don't again we have people who
have been bad actors in our communities
already I just read you the tip of the
iceberg of what I could have in the last
four years of people who have come into
New Hampshire who shouldn't be here
again this in the North in the Canadian
border we had he was a coyote it was the
second time trying to run people in he
had been caught in 2011 who knows how
many times he wasn't caught this was I
believe last fall and I'm not saying I'm
not a particular big one on the Canadian
border my biggest thing is just in
general some people are specific and are
very into the Canadian part I believe
most of
our illegal immigration is coming from
the south they're being bust up to
Boston or something and and again is it
as big a problem here as it is as you go
south no but once people who are get
into our country again I believe every
state is now a border state subject to
these people someone could go anywhere
in our country uh travel is very easy
and we would rather New Hampshire not
become a sanctuary State and I think
that's
enough thank you any
questions Senator with regard to the the
towns you mentioned um like I think you
said Lebanon
so is it the current policy on your
understanding that if they're booking
someone for a New Hampshire crime and
there's an ice detainer say for rape
that they're not allowed to call ICE oh
under provision seven I just happened to
pick one town over the other here
Lebanon uh no AG I can leave you these
no agent or agency of the city of
Lebanon including law enforcement shall
cooperate or participate in Immigration
enforcement actions as an agency
authorized communicate with the federal
immigrations yeah it's very clear that
they're being told not to cooperate not
to make the phone call not to do any
affirmative action so again we don't
want them enforcing federal law we just
want them to cooperate and we think the
cost will be di Minimus thank you
further
questions representative
Muse do we actually have any statistical
evidence of how many crimes are actually
being committed by people who are
undocumented
and how that actually compares to those
of us who have lived here all our lives
so yeah Senator Whitley has interesting
statistics and she will tell you that an
American is three times more likely to
commit a crime but I can explain why her
statistics are
flawed they do not look into the fact
that a lot of a lot of cities have been
aware for years if if they go to
prosecute someone in a courtroom they
will be deported because ice will come
they in Boston they will release them
out the back door it's anecdotal
evidence I don't have specific cases but
yes around the country your BL states do
not want to keep records of and they let
people out who are charged because they
know if they go for a felony charge or
something ice will show up and Deport
the people so the records aren't really
kept as far as how many they let them
out the back door so there's there're
statistically now because I don't think
anyone would believe I'm not saying they
these people are better or
worse but they're not being charged with
the crimes that would get them deported
because the judges are aware that this
deportation will result that Homeland
will show up that ice will show up so
they release them before they these
things happen just like they're told to
in Lebanon and Hanover they're told to
not cooperate not to make those phone
calls followup follow up so I didn't
hear anything in there about uh any
evidence so I don't have statistical
evidence one way or another that they do
more or less crimes but the statistical
evidence that was released in the Senate
was flawed evidence because Senator
forward represent n thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
thanks for talking to me um I'm
wondering okay so I see um on page three
uh starting at line 10 the section does
not authorize law enforcement uh a law
enforcement agency to detain an alien
unlaw unlawfully present in the United
States pursuant to immigration detainer
solely because the witness reported a
crime or was a victim of a criminal
offense and it goes it continues on to
talk about domestic violence to talk
about rape sexual exploitation sexual
assault these are um commonly used when
people are um in support of sanctuary
cities um this uh you know this
reasoning is commonly used as people
will not be able to report a crime will
not um feel comfortable interacting with
law enforcement if they have the threat
of something like this do you feel like
having this section in there um would
negate people's uh fear in in uh
interacting with law enforcement yeah so
I there is somewhere in there I have to
I haven't read it in a few weeks I
apologize but there is a section saying
that if you report it was to uh we had a
lot of Brazilian Community from
Nashville come to our hearing and um it
was pointed out to them and they came
and met with me after that if you do
report a crime that that you'll even be
helped to work towards you have like a
two-year period that they will not
report you to homelander ice and they'll
even try to help you get citizenship if
you report a crime so it's to get people
not to be scared of reporting so they
are covered there but I I will have to
while representative Harry
gine thank you m thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um on
line page two line 27 a lot for
enforcement agencies to use best efforts
to support the Environ enforcement of
Federal immigration laws um can
you describe to me what best efforts
mean is that just a it just me yeah so
we want them to make that phone call or
to drop them off and do if they call
Homeland call ICE let them know that's
all they have to do um they're just not
to let we would like them to cooperate
is to the best of their efforts it
doesn't mean they're going to hunt down
dishwashers and in Portsmith uh Senator
Perkins qu always it's like I'm a
welcoming community like no one's coming
to your community to go after immigrants
they're coming we just want to keep the
immigrants Community just as safe as us
and so we we do have Provisions in the
bill to assist people
who talk to let law enforcement know
that there have crimes have been
Witnesses and again best efforts will
not be you might hear that it's going to
be cost a lot of money again you make
that phone call is all we're asking for
detain them in jail for whatever brief
period that is or if you can't do that
drop them off in do at the federal
facility follow
follow
today if someone's arrested doesn't
matter who they are but if they believe
that this immigrant that's arrested and
they're booked do not they already know
if Isaac has um paperwork out for them
yeah they would know if they run the
name through and someone gave their
right name they and it pops up that
they're wanted by Ice yes they would
know and we want the police then to make
that phone call okay follow up one last
one follow up on the followup okay so
but what you're asking is that our law
enforcements do the work of Isaac by
making that call I'm not asking them to
go out and arrest anyone I'm not asking
them to spend or use any resources other
than you've encountered someone you were
doing with the state offense you've
arrested them brought them in and you
know that they're you know they've
either told you somehow you ran their
name and it came up on homeland so
you're aware and now you're going to
inform
Homeland we have Bill Ganon in custody
would you like to come pick them up and
if they say no you release
them who next thank you further
Muse one of the things that the bill uh
seems to require is for police officers
to make uh best efforts uh to contact uh
immigration officials
[Music]
um one of the things that I'm curious
about is you you seem to say that's
limited to just making a phone call I
mean and and best efforts really isn't
defined in the bill in any way um so is
this sort of a thing where we just sort
of make it up as we go along depending
on what the situation is or do you think
we actually need to have some real
standards uh in the bill around what
actually
constitute best efforts well if you look
at Lebanon and Hanover's or ordinances
they are very clear that would be a case
of worst efforts do not cooperate do not
make a phone call do not hold them do
not permit the immigration authority to
uh to talk to the person who's being
detained do not let the federal
immigrations even in your facility is
the case of Lebanon goes um do not
detain the person once they're done with
the state charge so that would be
totally going against that would be
worst efforts do not cooperate at all
again all we're asking for is you have
the person make the phone call um
contact the federal government and see
if this is a bad actor that they want to
detain because we haven't weeded them
out at the
border representative
Newman yeah I just have a question you
talk about they just happened to become
aware of this person is not a citizen in
in whatever the instance is how does
that happen does that mean they're going
to be asking for citizenship or how how
do if they stop somebody for speeding or
whatever the crime happens to be how do
they tell that they're not a citizen and
they should make the phone call so
usually so there's a ice agent who's
cooperated um he came in last year he
couldn't come in this year and he
testified that most of the time people
you know you're they're probably scared
I'm always scared when I get pulled over
by the police they tend to tell them
that you know here I am maybe they find
out at the jail the ice agent from
Chester New Hampshire said usually they
tell their status right away they said
I'm you know I don't have a driver's
license I'm not here legally and usually
it's forthcoming so they're not um
interrogating these people it's either
come out in Communications they've told
they've told the police when they're at
the jail they ran the name they gave the
right name and it came up it it ran in
the ice or the homeland security stuff
um so it has come to their attention
that the people are illegal I guess you
could lie and say you're someone else
and you might get away with it but once
the police know we'd like them to commun
to communicate that to the federal
government thank you representative here
gther
right thank you Mr chair um in New
Hampshire for the most part we truly
believe in local control not necessarily
State dictate what the city or town is
doing so obviously there's been an issue
from what you're saying with
levanon have you had conversation with
their folks in their whether it's their
chamber or wherever it might be I've
talked there's one of the Senators
represents Lebanon we've had a lot of
communication myself and her
um and then you're saying that the
problem is so we had um in Ry where we
had the mass murderer working on a
painting crew eating lunch with everyone
going out to restaurants there driving
through my towns on the way home to
marac if you have individual towns doing
their own thing you're putting the other
towns at risk so if you if Ry is going
to allow a mass murder there and not
look for them my bordering towns I have
three or four towns that border that
town you're putting all my citizens at
risk thank you Senator there be no
further question questions um thank you
for your thank you so we're going to
move on to the witness testimony now um
we have a significant number of
witnesses that are going to testify
today so I would ask that you please um
if you are turning in written testimony
try not to read us what you've already
going to hand in and we're going to
limit testimony to three minutes so try
to keep your points succinct and don't
repeat what other people have said um so
we can keep this down also we will be
working on this bill
um next Tuesday I'm going to hold a full
committee work session so if you plan to
come up and testify about how much you
don't like the language it might be
different language by next Tuesday so I
would I would caution not to be too
attached to what is written right now
and with that I will call the first
witness and that
[Music]
is representative Susan hillberg did I
say it
thank you Mr chairman for the record I'm
Susan elberger I represent Nashua uh
Ward one Hillsboro District
5 I was born and raised in
Manhattan uh which was a Gate City and I
now represent the gate City here in New
Hampshire all four of my Grandparents
were immigrants I'm a second generation
American all of us in this room as far
as I can tell are not native born or or
don't don't come from families that were
Native families all of us are immigrants
here some by choice some not um when I
was in my freshman year in college I met
uh I was assigned a roommate who was a
uh nice girl from a tiny town and had
never met a before in her
life and uh as we were getting
acquainted I was learning more about
Catholicism she was learning more about
me as a Jew as a New Yorker and I at one
point I said after I quizzed her about
her background I said do you have any
questions for me she thought for a
minute and she asked me where were my
horns I had no idea what she was talking
about so I asked her and she said you
know all all Jews have horns which was a
surprise to me because because i' never
met any Jews with horns and I knew an
awful lot of them Prejudice comes in a
lot of ways and whether we're asked
about our horns or about our
accents we tend to demonize people that
we see as other and we do that with
people whose languages are different or
colors are
different it doesn't work this country
is founded on immigrants all of us came
here families came here immigration
provides a thriving economy a thriving
sense of new ideas we have no proof that
immigrants are uh more likely to commit
crimes we can find statistics that
support us or not but we really don't
have any information to that
effect um having grown up in New York
the Statue of Liberty was a big deal for
me
uh the poem on it The New
Colossus uh talks about that statue as
the mother of Exiles that's what this
country is most of us know the lines uh
your huddle masses yearning to bre three
but the first line of the quotation in
there says keep ancient lands your
storied pump we want the ones here the
huddled masses who need what this
country can provide
we need to provide a way to make it
easier for them to be here and asking
our local police officers to help get
rid of them is not the way to go about
good
morning as you may be able to see I'm a
marine 100%
disabled Vietnam
veteran on my third deployment into the
southeast Asia I was a participant and
frequent Wind And for those who don't
recall the history that's the fall of
Saigon
I then went to the Philippines where I
met my fiance a Filipino woman and we
were married when I brought her back to
this country we did legal immigration we
filed I had to sign an Affidavit of
Support that she would never be a ward
of the state which I kept for 30 years
she was not I supported her I recently
spoke to her were on friendly terms
still she lives in San Francisco that
immigration uh immigrants there that are
all legal that she brought a family are
insense that we are allowing illegal
immigration into this country so what
we're talking today is not immigration
it's illegal immigration it's in the
code if you don't have permission to
immigrant I don't believe any taxpayer
money in the state of New Hampshire
should be used on illegal
immigration if you want to change the
laws to make it easier for people to
come that's
fine but the one question was asked just
recently by one of the
representatives about crimes how many
crimes well everyone that's illegal is
already committed one crime under the US
code so they're already committed a
crime in the chesha county the sherff
will not allow his deputies to cooperate
with ice unless they actually have a
felony
warrant now as a former police officer
if you stop somebody they have to
identify themselves if they don't have
an ID card or a driver's license then
you detain them until you can decide or
find out what their uh actual identity
is and if it means a call to Ice that's
what you do
to not enforce any law as a police
officer is a violation of your oath to
protect the
public we go to Massachusetts and it was
mentioned the prior gentleman that the
governor has asked Mass residents if
they have room to please take in
immigrants do we want that in New
Hampshire I have two spare bedrooms cuz
my wife and I keep our the same house
even though the children are gone
but I'm not going to house in I don't
money and in and uh right now in New
York illegals are given $1,400 under the
snap program the average American
citizen
family
$713 a
toe members of the House greeting my
name is mar I am a community organizer
uh Faith organizer at the gr State
organizing project and when I'm not
bringing your local pastors together to
work on making uh New Hampshire more
Beloved Community I am speaking and
performing at schools and
conferences uh you might catch me at the
um Multicultural Festival I'm throwing
it down um and which I was doing today
at
John um John Stark Regional High School
um of many of the places that I've uh
performed and um speak at and today it
was interesting because um I actually
got this shirt from uh the John Stark
Regional High School which it says
everyone
belongs um and uh the two things that uh
we really focused on was um having an
open being
open-minded um you know sometimes you
grow up in a small uh I grew up in
conquer um and sometimes you grow up in
a small town and it's easy to feel like
um that there is not a bigger World
outside of the uh place that you live in
and uh you know for uh someone like me
to come to the school and um being able
to connect with the students and being
able to uh really show them that um you
know to we have to be open-minded um
because we're even the people who are in
the in the same class with you they're
not the same and now imagine if someone
who uh lives in California or or maybe
lives in Mexico or maybe lives in
Liberia or Ivory Coast or um Europe
comes to your front door and um how how
do you receive that person how do you
hear their story um how's your heart
connecting with them which was the
second thing that we talked on was
empathy and empathy is the ability to
put yourself in someone else's shoes um
which was what we uh we were um doing at
John Stark today having these students
um be able to get out of the shelves um
most of them are coming you know from uh
different households um they have
different beliefs and I say listen it's
okay it's okay you have these different
beliefs but right now I need your heart
to be full of love um my heart is full
of love and this is where we can connect
with each other so I'm asking you today
to to vote no on this on this bill
because it it it doesn't allow you to
have your heart full of love it doesn't
allow you to be open-minded to the
person that's coming at your door and
and being able to listen to their story
so that's all today blessings thank
you thank you for your testimony um
before I call the next witness I want to
remind everyone although we are keeping
you to three minutes if you would like
to submit written testimony you can um
submit it through our portal email
portal and it will become part of the
record so with that I'll call the next
witness I'm going to have to step out
shortly cuz I have a medical appointment
but the vice chair is going to take over
for the remainder of the hearing um and
with that I'm going to the chair
Castello good afternoon chair and
members of the committee my name is Eva
Castillo I live in Manchester I'm a
citizen by
choice um I'm here to speak in
opposition of this bill
first of all uh I heard a lot of
misinformation here uh we are not being
invaded by anybody here in New Hampshire
uh we do not have the infrastructure to
House people uh people are not being
given money to live in any city um this
bill really doesn't do anything to keep
us safe I have worked for many many
years with different police departments
and uh uh to build trust in the
community a community is safer when
every person that lives in that
Community trusts the
police uh it is not true that the police
does not collaborate with ice when
people are committing a crime they are
turned over to ice the judges do not not
put charges on people
uh just to spare them from I you commit
a crime you pay the consequences with
immigration and with whatever criminal
uh punishment you you get being a
nondocumented person here is not a crime
it is a civil violation if you reenter
after being deported that's when it
becomes a crime but our police
departments all collaborate with ice the
different is that they're not going to
be just colonized when they find
somebody that run through a red light or
committed a traffic infraction and they
find out that they do not have a
driver's license but other than that
every time I needs their collaboration
they're there for them we have heard
opposition from the largest cities in
New Hampshire where most of the
immigrants live from you heard
opposition from the police departments
there we do not tell a captain of a
plane how to fly the planes how to
handle the plane you know why do we have
to tell police how to do their work they
know what's best for their
communities this uh Bill does nothing to
help New Hampshire this bill is going to
make us all less safe because when
people fear the police and I'm not you
know not only undocumented people fear
the police we come from places who are
our police departments are crooked
they're mean they're the rapist and
they're the bad people they're not an
honorable profession for the most part
like in this country so we come here and
we grow with having that fear in the
police and that's what we have inside in
our hard disk so it takes a while to
learn to to trust and to learn that not
what we had in our countries from police
is not what happens here many places the
police are also the arm of the of the uh
bad people so this doesn't happen here
our police departments have worked
really hard to make sure that every
citizen that lives in New Hampshire
every person trust them so they can
protect all of us so please do the right
thing and just itl this Bill thank you
thank you Miss
Castello no questions who do we
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Jim McConnell you
have I hope uh received my testimony I
will not burden you with reading the
testimony but I do want to call your
attention to the back of the testimony
which reproduces title 8 us code 1252 C
authorizing state and local law
enforcement officials to arrest and
detain certain illegal
immigrants in particular I want to call
attention to authorizing state and local
law enforcement officials to arrest and
detain certain illegal
aliens state and local law enforcement
officials are authorized to arrest and
detain an individual who number one is
an alien illegally pres in the United
States and number two has previously
been convicted of a
felony armed robbery rape think about
felonies in the United States and
deported left the United States after
such conviction so the bottom line
is that barring our police and other law
en forcement
agencies from
participating in the effort to help ice
rid the country and our cities in this
state of those who convicted felonies
should be
everybody's first choice I don't really
see any reason why this is controversial
in the slightest unless you want your
communities to welcome convicted
felons this should be a
no-brainer and I'm certainly hoping that
you will
OTP Senate Bill
563 I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony there any
am okay sir are you speaking to the non
gerain amendment that was okay just so
just so you know I don't want you to
have you're welcome to stay as as long
as you like um but when we open that I
am going to have to recess that until um
a week from today um the prime sponsor
had to leave for a a last minute medical
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Maggie Fogerty
I'm the New Hampshire program director
for the American friend service
committee a 106 years old Quaker founded
organization working for human rights
around the world and we have written
testimony which I'll submit it's quite
lengthy um but I'll just just want to
lift up two or three key messages within
the two minutes that I
requested so I'm here today on behalf of
the New Hampshire immigrant rights
Network it's a Statewide network of more
than 200 individuals and organizations
nonprofits immigrant support
organizations Refugee resettlement
Advocates and
attorneys working together to improve
the lives of immigrants in New Hampshire
and to ensure their just treatment and
as a coalition we are adamantly opposed
to SB
563 we urge you to find it itl we urge
you to unanimously find it itl our key
points are that there simply are no
Sanctuary cities in New Hampshire this
is We Believe an intentional misnomer
meant to generate alarm about a
non-existent problem New Hampshire has a
full complement of federal law
enforcement officers including
immigration enforcement who regularly
interact with state and local law
enforcement and they have an established
relationship that is working for them
which is why you have heard from law
enforcement leaders from the state's
largest cities to say that this bill
they did not ask for it they do not need
it and they do not want it and that is
why they describe this bill as
unnecessary and
ill-advised the language that's being
used to describe the need for this bill
to address a a situation of undocumented
immigration in New Hampshire is not only
toxic it comes from a long tradition in
this country of pitting groups of people
against each other blaming the other for
all manner of problems whether it's
housing or employment or public health
and it's careless with regard to
definitions the word undocumented is
applied to many many groups of people
who have permission to be here they
might have an application in process
they might be exercising their legal
right to seek asylum in the United
States they might have one of the
temporary permissions that exist in
terms of deferred action for childhood
arrivals or temporary protected status
so the language and support of this bill
not only is intended to generate fear
but it's inaccurate and
imprecise this bill the the people
likely to suffer most from this bill are
those US citizens and immigrants who
will be targeted as looking like an
immigrant and we know that that
generates racial profiling and feeds
racial bias New Hampshire needs
newcomers they're an essential part of
our community health and well-being an
essential part of our Workforce and our
economy and regardless of an immigrant's
status in the US this bill sends a
message do not come do not bring your
family members here it is not a safe
place so there are others behind me who
will talk about the the legal and
constitutional problems with this bill
but I wanted to leave you with our core
message our letter is s has five pages
of signatures Faith leaders nonprofit
leaders and others expressing their
opposition to this bill I also have a
packet of data that I think will be
helpful to your understanding of the
reality of of immigrants and their
presence in our state I'm happy to
have no questions thank you very much
for your testimony thank
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee I'm Bob Dunn the
director of public policy for the Roman
Catholic dasis of Manchester and I'm
here today on behalf of Bishop Peter
labashi to respectfully register our
opposition to SB
563 when uh I became assistant
commissioner of the Department of Safety
back in 1992 one of the first things I
learned and nothing over the last 30
years has changed my mind on this is
that the department of safety and the
New Hampshire Chiefs of Police
Association have never been shy about
coming before the
legislature when they thought that there
was some change that could be made to
New Hampshire law that would best
protect the public safety and so uh I
think that it's significant that while
this bill has been brought
forward uh as something to advance the
public safety it has not been proposed
by the very people that we have tasked
with protecting the Public Safety in New
Hampshire you've heard about the
concerns of uh what will happen if a
bill like this passes and people uh are
not inclined to go into to report crimes
and that's um something that is
significant because if people don't
report crimes then it makes it more
likely that criminals are going to be
able to Prey Upon people that are
already in a very vulnerable situation
and so as a result uh we respectfully
think that the question of how New
Hampshire law enforcement authorities
decide to use their discretion with
respect to ice detainers is something
that the state should leave to the
discretion of the people that are the
experts in this that we've asked we've
tasked to decide what is the best way to
advance the public safety and with that
I'll close my testimony thank
you thank you thank you very much I
I I would just like to remind all of our
guests here that are here today while um
we have somebody that has their time to
be heard it is difficult for the
committee to hear if there are um side
conversations going so if you could
please um refrain from doing that that
would be here very helpful to all of us
thank
good afternoon thanks for uh allowing me
the opportunity to testify in strong
support of Senate Bill 563 on behalf of
the Federation for American Immigration
Reform we are a nonprofit nonpartisan
organization that was founded in 1979 we
have 3 million members and supporters
and approximately 4,000 in New Hampshire
if enacted s SP 563 would prohibit
jurisdictions from employing dangerous
policies that provide a safe haven or
sanctuary in which illegal aliens can
work and live without fear of
apprehension from immigration officials
I am going to narrow my testimony down
to some key points uh you all should
have received my written testimony which
is more specific proponents of sanctuary
policies argue that enacting anti-
Sanctuary legislation like SB 563 will
result in public officials and Law
Enforcement Officers discriminating
against minorities however this issue
has been addressed in the bill itself s
SP 563 prohibits discrimination saying
that a state or local government entity
shall not consider an individual's race
color religion language or national
origin additionally opponents of the
bill will say that anti- Sanctuary
legislation requires New Hampshire to
enforce immigration laws which is the
responsibility of the federal government
the truth is this legislation only
ensures that state and local officials
cannot block or prohibit communication
and cooperation with Federal immigration
officials moreover there's no
requirement in the bill for public
officials or law enforcement to comply
with detainers issued by immigration
officials it also it only says that
cooperation cannot be prohibited we've
heard a lot about detainers detainers
are simply requests made by law
enforcement officers asking another law
enforcement agency to hold an individual
for up to 48 hours so that individual
can be picked up by an officer or agency
making the
request therefore New Hampshire
officials are not arresting individuals
on immigration matters detainer requests
are not solely related to immigration in
fact law enforcement officers are
routinely asked by US Marshals or other
law enforcement agencies to detain in
individuals um likewise I want to touch
on the committing crimes at a lower rate
um the assumption that illegal aliens
commit crimes at lower rates than
American citizens is not true we had a
study in 2019 of data from the federal
government state Criminal Alien
assistance program scap that illegal
aliens are more likely to be
incarcerated in state prisons and county
jails than US citizens and legal
immigrants in fact in this report in the
states examined it found that illegal
aliens are incarcerated up to five and a
half times as frequently as Citizens and
legal
immigrants Additionally the the report
found that states with the highest
incarceration rates of illegal aliens
are also those that have the highest if
sure
she
e
thank you
everybody please accept my apology for
needed to take a recess if you would
please like to continue with your
testimony sure thank you so much for
allowing me to
testify
[Music]
um in F schal year 2023 which ended in
September ice arrested 1
17,5 190 illegal immigrants inside the
country almost 45% with criminal records
criminal aliens had an average of four
charges and convictions each including
more than 33,000 charges or convictions
for assault 7500 for weapons offenses
1,713 for homicide related criminal
offenses and
1,615 for kid kidnapping removals also
included
3,46 known or suspected gang
members moreover state and local
cooperation with ice does not reduce the
number of non-citizens reporting crimes
or coming forward with testimony being
criminalized besides the fact that
anonymous tips can be given there are
already a number of programs that allow
state and local police to encourage
victim and witness cooperation by
granting lawful status to illegal aliens
who add in the prosecution of criminals
if illegal aliens provide helpful
information to police they may qualify
for UTS or vaa non-immigrant visas which
in turn would ultimately allow them to
apply for permanent legal status in the
United States Sanctuary policies
actually prevent illegal alien victims
of crime from taking advantage of these
programs in addition according to a
recent report by the senator for
immigration studies the data from the
Department of Justice National Crime
victimization survey shows that
immigrant VI victimizations are just as
likely and in some cases more likely to
be reported to police than crimes
against the native born ice has just two
20,000 employees only half of who are
dedicated to the apprehension and
removal of illegal immigrants the
cooperation of state and local
enforcement who number about 900,000
strong is a force multiplier vital to
fiing out those Among Us who wish to
cause us harm if isce is forced to go
into community rather than the secure
environment of local jails many who wish
us harm will not be removed and others
cooperation we actually let you go over
a little bit because we had a disruption
but I'm happy to take questions if need
Balden thanks for taking my question um
in your written testimony you said that
um New Hampshire taxpayers spend one uh
17.5 million annually on expenses
resulting from illegal immigration do I
understand correctly that the
methodology for that study was um just
to overestimate the cost of existing in
New Hampshire and then uh divide that by
the estimated number of the guesstimated
number of um
illegal or undocumented individuals in
the state so the methodology was used by
our research team they looked at the
number of um illegal aliens plus their
us-born children um and figured out
based on costs of Education cost of
Justice costs of of Health Care Etc how
much it would cost um each year above
the amount that they paid in their
taxes
so it's they we do recognize they pay
taxes and or a lot of them do um so that
is the amount that it's costing beyond
that follow
up do I understand correctly that in
this methodology you assumed that all of
these undocumented individuals are on
Medicaid and consuming uh several other
programs and receiving welfare uh we do
not assume it's based on numbers that we
can find out um it is not an assumption
there is some Des work as to the numbers
but um yeah as far as the the number of
illegal aliens in the state because they
are not accurate records as to that but
it's based on
reports representative
Muse can you tell me a little bit more
about your organization and and
specifically why the Southern Poverty
Law Center has actually identified you
as a hate group it representative Muse
that plea please disregard that is not
that is not
okay why isn't that okay representative
Muse that is not an acceptable
Muse
e
no
know
welcome back we will continue our public
hearing
for Senate Bill 563 and the committee
recognizes uh G
thank you thank you madam chair members
of the committee my name is jel bisett
and the legal director at the ACLU of
New Hampshire we respectfully um oppose
this bill and would uh recommend that it
be deemed inexpedient to legislate and I
think this is I know I have very limited
time and I know we've been here for a
while and I'll try to make my points
very brief but I think this is really
kind of a rare moment where you have
groups like the ACLU New Hampshire
Liberty Alliance Municipal Association
and many in law enforcement um all
opposing this bill for many reasons and
I think that is kind of an overall sign
that this bill may be problematic in
various ways and I'm just going to share
with you a few reasons why we think this
bill is is problematic um first I do
want to say that I know that there's
been some data um about undocumented
individuals and crime um there is kind
of a running dispute with respect to
that data and I'll I'll make sure that I
provide that uh in an email to the
committee so I don't spend a lot of time
today talking about that um but I do
want to to start at the outset I know
that there was some testimony that this
is you know a voluntary you know Bill
you know municipalities you know um
comply with detainers they they can
elect to not comply with detainers I
just don't think that's true um when you
look at this bill uh and the intent
behind it I mean this is a
mandate that local police do the federal
government's bidding with respect to
Federal immigration enforcement and it
does so uh without any training funds
for training without funds for
compliance and of course without funds
for any litigation costs that may
emanate from from this bill and and not
only does it require compliance with
detainers um it goes even further right
to state that quote a law enforcement
agency shall use best efforts to support
the enforcement of federal immigration
law now I know that there was some
testimony Hey listen we're just trying
to get at trying to make sure that local
police make calls but best efforts means
best efforts it is incredibly broad it
is not defined and I think plausibly it
it it could mean a whole host of things
not just a call but having to hold
people for ice at Ice's request when a
local police department may not have the
resources capacity or ability to do it
or funding to do it particularly in
smaller communities you can imagine how
that would be a significant burden best
efforts could also plausibly mean you
know ice wants to conduct an immigration
checkpoint where they stop everyone and
they want you to comply uh they want
your services well under this bill best
efforts I think a very strong reading of
that statute is you need to go do that
for federal immigration enforcement may
not be the intent but I do think it is
incredibly um incredibly broad that
sentence because there's a robust
enforcement mechanism as well that
accompanies this bill um and of course
it does mandate compliance with
detainers because if you voluntarily
elect to say we're not going to you know
comply with detainers that is a
sanctuary policy right that is
prohibited under the bill and that and I
think really at its core what this
undermines is the notion that really in
New Hampshire we know we don't require
our local towns du the bidding of the
federal government and in fact with
respect to the things that the federal
government's supposed to do we let them
do it and lastly with detainers I just
want to be very clear there's no due
process baked in them I articulate that
um in our in our testimony um and lastly
I just would really strongly encourage
the committee to read the the letter
submitted by many of the leaders um in
law enforcement um that have expressed
serious and real concerns with this
particular piece of
legislation thank you for your testimony
are there any
thank you madam chair for taking my
testimony and thank you to members of
the committee um for hearing all of us
this afternoon um so I will also be
brief I will simply introduce myself
first and say that my name is Grace K
thank you so much for pronouncing my
name correctly um my name is Grace kand
I'm the program coordinator for the
American friend service committee I am a
longtime granted stator lifelong granted
stator and I'm also an immigrant from
the Democratic Republic of Congo um I
came to the United States when I was 2
years old and for the majority of the
the time that I have lived in the United
States I have been undocumented and so
I've heard I've had to sit in the
audience and hear a lot of testimony
about what quote unquote illegal
immigrants can and cannot do what we
believe they take away from our
communities and I'm here to say that we
our our role our work together both as
advocates and as legislators is to make
New Hampshire a safe and a safe state
that is welcoming and a and able makes
it possible for all who live here to be
able to live here with uh support and to
feel welcome here and so as an
undocumented immigrant I was an
undocumented immigrant when I was going
to Webster School ofer elementary I was
an undocumented immigrant when I made
the Honor role at Bishop Brady High
School I was an undocumented immigrant
with my mother who is a longtime nurses
assistant worked in almost every single
nursing home uh both at the county level
and the local level in Manchester taking
care of community members and family
members I'm sure possibly even taking
care of even some of your loved ones and
so I think it is really important for us
to consider what is the spirit of this
bill what does this bill actually do
does it truly make our community our
state a safer one does it truly uh solve
the problem that uh the sponsors have
stated is is there to be solved or does
it in fact send a clear message not only
to Immigrant community members but to
Immigrant loved ones because immigrant
communities are not a separate uh entity
living apart from other residents um and
citizens of the state we are part of
your families we are your colleagues uh
we are in your your schools uh we are in
your grocery stores we are part of the
fabric of this community and not only do
we contribute billions of money and tax
dollars uh to the state without being
able to access any of the uh the the the
social safety nets that some people here
have claimed um that IM uh undocumented
immigrants can we cannot we cannot get
on Medicare we cannot receive welfare we
cannot do a lot of things and yet we
still continue to contribute to this
great state and so I have the immense
privilege of now being um a US citizen
um but I know that it is important my
work is to continue to raise the profile
and raise the voices of communities that
I come from knowing that not so long ago
I was in those communities and we are
not talking simply um we need to examine
intent versus impact and the int the
impact of this bill is that it will make
it that much more difficult that much
more scary that much less welcoming in
our state not only for immigrants but
also for the people who love them who
work with them and are part of their
lives and so I strongly urge the
committee to really to consider what
kind of state are we trying to be let us
not fall into fear let us not fall into
the false rhetoric that pits us against
each other other but to really examine
that there are many ways that we can
contribute to a safer New Hampshire but
this is not one of them so thank you for
taking my testimony I'm happy to take
questions thank you very much for your
testimony there representative celik
thank you so much and thank you for
taking my question um you said in your
testimony that you were not eligible to
receive Services um could could you
expand on that just a little bit more
for us please yes so absolutely so um I
come from a single parent household my
mother was a single mother my father
having passed away when I was only four
years old and so she was a widow raising
a child alone and so um Not only was she
uh a single parent she were poor working
class she worked multiple jobs um in
nursing homes and she was eligible for
many she would have been eligible for
many different services including
Medicaid Medicare um as well as Wick all
these all these uh uh care packages that
we have available to lowincome families
with um with children but because we
were undocumented we were not eligible
for any of those services and that um
that fact continues today so that we
have even undocumented families now in
2024 would not be eligible for those
Services followup um and was was your
mother in your case as you brought her
up paying taxes during that time oh
absolutely my mother worked for like I
said for all different Nur nursing homes
in the state of New Hampshire she pay
taxes every single year and in fact even
I when I was able to finally get some
work um I worked as an art model um I
know I'm very pretty um worked as an art
model I worked at a Chinese restaurant
and I paid my taxes my first tax that I
uh income tax that I filed was for
$7,000 worth of income in one year and I
still pay taxes on that so we have been
paying taxes for decades as many others
have as
well representative Reed thank you m
Madam chair thank you for taking my
question um what do what is the obstacle
or obstacles that prevent um people from
getting um citizenship when they're here
for a majority of their lives it seems
easier in my from my point of view to
start the process so you get benefits
that you contribute to it just sounds
very difficult to navigate the system
the way it is so can you shed some light
on why it's hard for children brought
here and go so long without citizenship
thank you yes absolutely thank you for
that question so I know I will use my
own case as an example the reality is is
that our immigration system uh many
folks I'm sure you've heard the phrase
of uh speak to the fact of claiming that
people need to get into line you need to
get in line don't don't don't uh don't
uh you know cross over somebody else but
the reality is is within the immigration
system there aren't a lot of Pathways to
be able to regularize your sta
so for instance in my case I came to the
United States on a Visa um technically
legal and then I fell out of status very
shortly thereafter and so for decades I
there was no way for me to regularize my
status um there were we had the
opportunity to be granted Asylum our
case was particularly complicated so it
really because it takes the burden of
proof for Asylum cases is on the
petitioner right and so there isn't a
lot of Pathways there's not a lot line
to get into and so that's why a lot of
people who are like me people who were
on deferred action for childhood
arrivals children who came as uh came as
children and became undocumented there
simply isn't a path forward and so even
for myself my own story the only way
that I was able to regularize is through
my marriage to my spouse who I've been
with for 15 years um but if that wasn't
the case if we had broken up if we had
decided not to get married I would still
be sitting here with deferred action for
childhood childhood arrivals I would not
be a a documented
resident representative
Bowden thanks for taking my question
earlier we heard about this number
107 million is what it costs New
Hampshire have undocumented immigrants
um my understanding is the study
includes costs attributed to immigrants
being on Medicaid can you speak to that
so I unfortunately cannot I don't quite
have the numbers I will just say that it
costs the state money to have anybody
living here um but I think what's also
important to look at in terms of that
kind of data is how much money do people
contribute to the state and whether in
tax dollars um locally or at the state
you is
this if the Mr Halt and if there is
anybody here that wishes to testify that
has not turned in a pink card now is
your time to do so because this is our
Bill have another person coming up hi uh
thank you for hearing me my name is
David Holt I'm here to oppose SB 563
which is going to make the state unsafe
for me and everyone here
um I'm opposed to this as a are police
across the state uh I'm a second
generation immigrant my grandmother came
here actually before there was any
immigration legislation as so many did
unless you are an indigenous person or a
person who's is descended from people
that were brought here against their
will um I guess I would like to ask have
you been out in our community lately you
can't walk five feet without seeing a
help wanted sign there is a labor
shortage and we need immigrants to work
and many do jobs that no one else will
do
uh without immigrations New Hampshire's
populations would have shrunk last
year um along the same line there's a
housing shortage and who are the people
that work in construction it's mostly
immigrants um and the problem is
with all of the the anti-immigrant uh
actions that are taking place if we
decrease the number we're going to have
even less housing uh constructed so
we're biting off our nose despite our
face uh with the limited uh resources
that developers have these days they're
of course choosing to uh build the more
profitable luxury apartments which are
not helping out uh any of our
citizens um we should all be aware that
the federal government is responsible
for immigration uh specifically this is
planned out so that state and local
police can build positive relationships
with everyone in our community uh this
bill will Foster a lack of trust among
all immigrants and bipo and everyone
else in our community uh fostering
racism and it will make us or our state
less safe um one of the things that has
come up uh previously was uh about taxes
uh immigrants actually do pay taxes they
contribute to our economy but even when
they are naturalized which usually takes
years and years there is then a 5year
waiting period or gap before they're
able to accept or receive any uh
benefits um the there are refugees which
are a very small portion of immigrants
that actually do receive sub assistance
but it is uh
laughable um and then I'd also like to
state if you all have a a cell phone if
you could just Google uh Fair you'll
find that the Southern Poverty Law
Center has named that to be a hate group
it's easy to find for anyone thank you
Davis yes thank you I thought card had
been submitted so I'm glad you mentioned
that thank you uh Reverend John gregy
Davis with my partner Susan I co-pastor
the Congregational Church in Meridan New
Hampshire where we've been for the past
30 years
and we are one of three Sanctuary
churches in New Hampshire and we live
just below Lebanon Hanover those
pernicious communities that have
declared themselves welcoming and
therefore must be hot beds of dangerous
potential anti-terrorists I mean
terrorists I'm sorry I would just
suggest that we've had just the opposite
experience and I want to begin first by
expressing some dismay that we've
allowed the language of illegal to be
used too many times today you know a
young woman from China in our
congregation want asked me how can any
human being be illegal I'll leave it to
you to answer that I said to her no
human being is illegal there may be
people are undocumented but they are not
illegal so I hope henceforth we will not
use that language I want to just submit
that the this legislation is based upon
fear uh and imagines terrible people the
next 911 terrorists I mean we could we
could argue that in my mostly White
Community where people like me reside
we're harboring the next uh Timothy
McVey it's it's it's it's it's
ridiculous in terms of saying that just
because someone looks like a terrorist
that everyone else who looks like them
is going to be terrorists we had the
privilege of hosting a Brazilian family
in our home for eight months it was a
tremendous benefit to our family they I
wish I could snap my fingers for a
moment and make every undocumented
immigrant disappear from this nation I
suspect I'd hear a great howl and outcry
what's happening where are all the
services that we've taken for granted I
didn't know until we had Brazilians
living with us that for example many
Brazilians clean clean the buildings
overnight that many of us expect to be
clean when we go into the the
opportunity there our kids play with
their kids they are neighbors their
language their culture enriches Our
Lives as well and I'm sure you've heard
from a number of people from our church
already saying that uh we would we would
urge you to um to to urge your
opposition to this bill and I want just
conclude with uh the last line of my
testimony which I'll submit to you just
saying that s SP 563 is unnecessary and
harmful and does not reflect the New
Hampshire values of hospitality and
Community safety our imigrant friends
and neighbors throughout our state and
we their friends and neighbors are
counting on you to oppose this misguided
Bill thank
you representative Reed thank you thank
you for taking my question does your
church receive any funds from the
federal or state government for taking
in any of our um immigrant population
wow that would be so nice no that
somehow that questions never come up
about offering us funds no it's been
quite the opposite actually or or at
least we've needed to rely on on our own
resources and fortunately we've had an
outpouring of resources to help us with
that
and
Lewis good afternoon everyone good
afternoon my name is Avalon Lewis uh I
want to thank you for um having me speak
here today this is my first time so it's
a little bit nerve-wracking a little bit
nervous I hope that you would bear with
me
um currently I reside in Nashua at 22
King Street but I came to this country I
too am an immigrant I came to this
country in
1972 um as a visitor I then turned
around and um applied well my family
applied for permanent residency for me
and although all of my siblings made it
I did not I was not accepted simply
because I had aged
out I had to start the whole process all
over on my own to become a legal
resident because I aged out the
immigration let's call it Im Just
immigration
um put me in a status of
illegal
immigrant and I was told
told in so many words that if I kept my
nose clean not caus any problems that
um I wouldn't have an issue and that
would allow me to continue my
preparations for legal
residency and I was successful at
that now before I gained legal residency
I had no access to any of the privilege
of of a legal or of a citizen of the
because I was an illegal immigrant an
illegal
alien I gained my residency my permanent
residency but I was still limited to
what I
could access as far as um Federal
programs and and stuff like that I too
accepted
that because I wasn't a
citizen I became a citizen and it
allowed me or afforded me a whole lot of
other benefits that this country
provides and I like that I cannot
understand why people are
making
excuses for becoming a legal resident of
the country
in any country you go to I travel a lot
right now I travel abroad in any country
you go to you have to
register being in that country because
they want to know who's coming in who's
for that is their
law that is the law of the United States
I have no issue with
that Mr Lewis if you could just fin
finish up that sentence I'm sorry but
your three minutes is up oh okay well um
I am in favor of this bill I definitely
am
um if you are in the country you should
be
legal that's all I have to say
thank you thank you very much any
questions representative scitec IR
irrespective of your position your first
time was
great I'm
sorry it's not a question your first
time testifying you did a very nice job
thank you oh thank you very much I
appreciate that now gives me CR greater
confidence for the next one yeah we hope
that you'll come back and join us again
thank you is there anybody else here
that has not turned in a pink card that
wishes to testify seeing none we will
close the Senate the hearing for Senate
Bill
563 and we will open the public hearing
for Senate Bill
578 and recognize the prime sponsor as
soon as I can find the bill to find out
is
okay if you could just give us one
so
thank you good afternoon chair and
members of house criminal justice and
public safety for the record my name is
suen state center from District 5
covering large parts of Grafton a part
of salivan County and one Community
marac County the beautiful town of New
London I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce to you today Senate Bill
578 this bill provides that individuals
who are indigen and charged with a crime
do not have to pay the cost of their own
electronic monitoring equipment if their
case terminates without a conviction for
any offense and I want you to hold in
your mind plea deals until we get to the
end of this bill because I have a a
suggestion to make kind of on the fly
but I I would appreciate your Indulgence
um this bill actually came the idea for
this bill came from work that you'd
already been doing in the area of bail
reform um and is tailored to meet uh you
know fit in with a particular part of
you know the pre-trial monitoring to
pull that out I've actually had talked
to representative Roy about the work on
this in the Senate so that we could find
a way to bring this about either through
this one tailored bill or through what I
ultimately hope is a broader package so
the idea started here um and we were
listening I had been listening to some
of the experiences from different
counties from folks who had been um who
had been through trials or incarcerated
different counties and as you may
remember there was an individual um from
straford County Corrections that said
said something that really struck you
know struck me and it also stuck with me
which was that the cost was $5 a day for
an electronic monitoring if they if they
had if it was a requirement for them to
wear one which sometimes which if they
couldn't pay that physical labor was
required I'm not necessarily like I
understand that there needs there need
to be conditions in place but I'm not
sure that this is the best way to get at
it considering that this could cost up
to
$150 or more and for some who are
struggling already to pay rent
supporting their families trying to hold
down one or more jobs I think that
there's a tradeoff here where we have to
think about do we want them to be in a
County Jail what it costs per day to be
in a County Jail versus is what we may
excuse for that period of time and
especially and and in particularly if
their case ends um without any it
terminates without any type of
conviction so I'm asking to think about
what that tradeoff might be I would
prefer to keep folks who it's again
appropriate and who can't afford this
out of prison with their families
working um within their communities and
staying connected up until a point where
there's a conviction or not U and it
just seems this seems to be in my
experience both serving locally as well
as here is that it's not our way to
force the lower income members of our
community to do things such as might
maybe be phys physical labor to pay for
a device who've been charged with a
crime and have not yet had a trial now I
know this is only one story but I just
again want you to think about this in
the broader context um
I wanted to make it clear and I had
already stated this that I think there
needs I'm not suggesting that there
should be nothing at all but we should
consider how to approach this um rather
than rather than you know labor there's
still if there needs to be some there
needs to be the pre-trial electronic
monitoring I'm all in favor of that it's
how is that paid for especially when
they're Char they're innocent until
proven guilty and the way the bill is
written it sets it up so that that
determination not of their status on the
crime but whether they qualify for this
pre-trial monitoring electronic
monitoring is done up in front um and
then if the case terminates without a
conviction they don't have to pay that
back I still contend and we don't have
all of the data and I understand the
county will speak to some of the count
representative from the Cy's Association
will speak to some of this but I I still
contend that that would be um
potentially less than what it would cost
up to close to $300 a day for them to be
in a um in a
jaila so you know these bracelets
again the the well the electronic
monitoring devices they serve an
important purpose for somebody again
who's been determined that they are not
and they've not committed a serious
crime that they are you know going to go
to trial for they're not a threat or a
danger to the community uh we want to
put them back in the community again be
with their families work their jobs you
know support their families and be
connected U this is a way to achieve
that but again not everyone can afford
that $5 a day and you know I have to say
um my own you know it's like my own
Catholic guilt moment is that when I go
and I buy my daily cup of coffee I spend
just about that and to think that
somebody else doesn't have that money to
cover a cost like this is you
know I I'm starting to think twice about
that and my mother has reminded me so
again not being found guilty of a
crime done at the beginning of you know
the the process using the indigen
Defense Language um that has been you
know there's some precedent on this as
well um in in statute and and as well as
in the court system using that language
U so that we have a that we have a place
to go with this so I'm proposing again
that
we that we set up the system where if
somebody at pre-trial it's required for
them to have an electronic monitoring
device if we use the Indigent Defense
Language to narrow that down to that
they qualify for this that we're not
charging them per day if they are
cleared um when their case terminates so
plea deals um I hear there's a concern
that's come up recently about plea deals
not being covered and how many people
plea out and that this could again
become a cost for the counties this is
very new to me today I wasn't aware of
it so I would ask for the possibility to
work further with the counties to see if
we can amend this because we've actually
amended this already once working with
County government to try to make this
work I'd like the opportunity to do that
again if you should so see fit um so
thank you very much for your time and um
I know you have a busy afternoon I'll do
my best to answer any questions you may
have thank you very much representative
man did you have a question
representative
Muse
hi um I do have a question about um your
bill versus um the bail bill which is uh
uh HB 318 that just went over to the
Senate um there are um there are
Provisions uh for the state to pay uh
for uh monitoring and pre-trial services
for people who are Indigent in that bill
uh but I believe it's only in the cases
in in the case of 3 318 it's only for uh
uh protective uh monitoring and and and
misdemeanor domestic violence cases
where people are released so your bill
would actually apply beyond that wider
for any any reason a person may actually
uh be asked to be monitored right
correct and again not deemed by the
judge a threat to Public Safety it is
not a you know a a higher a higher
charge quick followup followup and uh I
I just have you had a chance to uh
review the language of 318 and and if
you have um what did you think are there
conflicts are there are there things in
there that uh need to be incorporated
that are part of your bill so thank you
um representative Muse for not just the
first question but the second one so I I
have and I've also spoken um with
representative Roy about this in trying
to um you know in I think that the
there's a lot of intentionality between
the two of them uh mine is a little
broader the the the house bill is a
little narrower but I think they could
get us close to the same place so I what
I'd like is for one or the other to land
and I like the I I'm you know partial to
the to working on the bail reform but if
there's if things don't settle um with
that in the Senate this would give us at
least one piece to work with so thank
you thank
you this is your sign to please pass our
bail bills I I hear
you I don't see any further questions
thank you for your testimony oh you're
welcome and thank you
up good afternoon Representatives Madame
Vice chair uh I'm Erin Creed I'm the
general counsel for the judicial branch
and I'm appearing as hype woman for Kate
Horan uh but Kate Horan from the New
Hampshire Association
counties thank you so much um I know
we've had an opportunity to speak in the
past about similar Concepts while you
were working on your bail package and
I've appreciated so much the ability to
work with so many of you um we did have
some follow on conversations in the
finance committee I know you're you're
part of those as well um for those who
are coming from other states or from the
federal system they may believe that
there's a robust pre-trial division in
the New Hampshire judicial branch that
doesn't happen to be the case in New
Hampshire we don't administer any
electronic monitoring and we do not have
any staff uh that works in this area
electronic monitoring in the state of
New Hampshire is administered by the
counties um so we worked uh with rep Roy
and others to change uh HB 318 to sort
of voluntarily transmission transmit
some of those responsibilities from the
courts over to the counties where the
expertise and the knowledge is um I
think the Senate helpfully improved this
bill by adding the counties in my
suggestion would be to to take the
courts out uh and then you will have
completed uh the transition over to the
party with the most knowledge and and
responsibility in the area um we do not
have a policy position as we generally
do not on the underlying Bill however
I'm happy to give you any technical
feedback that you might find useful and
otherwise I transmit you to the counties
for more expertise on electronic
monitoring thank you Aaron um thank you
members of the committee um so just to
start at front we are happy to work with
Senator Apprentice on any language that
she would like to to amend or see uh and
I'll Echo aerin's comments that we did a
lot of work in Senate Finance around
House Bill 318 and we believe that is
the method that goes forward just a
couple of concerns the counties wanted
to flag for everyone um so we do believe
that collecting fees after someone has
been convicted is going to be an
administrative burden on someone right
now it's done by weekly uh or bi-weekly
depending upon the county cuz as you all
remember from your study this last fall
each County's program is very very
different uh to address the straford uh
call so no one is forced to do labor um
we work with straford County works with
each person who is on electronic
monitoring to find something that they
are willing to do if they are unable to
pay back so that could be yes they do
have the option to do wood stacking
because straford County does cut and uh
sell wood and that's a profit to to the
county uh you can also work with Special
Olympics who happens to be their charity
for this year in doing office things
stuffing envelopes things like that
sometimes you know somebody wants to get
outside and was the the sheriff's
Cruisers great we will work with you to
find something that you want to do but I
just want to be clear no one is forced
to do hard labor to get on electronic
monitoring
um and I'll leave it that you guys can
can uh read our letter but just the
concern getting so most people don't get
a conviction most people end up with a
plea deal that's not a conviction the
way this bill is written and the fact
that we have to wait until they're
convicted very we hold very few
convicted inmates most of them are going
to the state prison where we may or may
not ever see them again so um but happy
has did you have a question
Representative no thank you madam chair
and I just wanted to clarify I'm going
through and what you had said was to
remove the court um and so I'm going
through here I got um in line six um
shall be paid for by the New Hampshire
Court in which the defendant is charged
that court is providing and requiring
electronic monitoring so what you're
saying is that it's not the case for one
thing um so it doesn't necessarily apply
I just want to kind of be clear about
things that might need to be uh amended
in this um that would make it
appropriate so I'm kind of looking for
different references but the one thing
um that I wanted to um discuss
specifically is as I'm going through and
finding those specific things there's
the court shall develop uniform criteria
to evaluate and determine so that's kind
of something that is the responsibility
of the court it's not in a list as most
of these are as the the the court the
county or agency this is something that
is specifically assigning that to the
court so what would we be replacing that
with great question and I I will turn it
over to Kate in just one moment but you
had very similar uh language in your
bail package and I do believe that the
counties asked for that to be changed
that it would be the counties making
that determination in that instance as
well uh you know certainly it's your
policy judgment if you want the courts
to be more involved but I can turn it
over to Kate to tell you a little bit
more about how the counties would
administer that sure so uh I'll just
point out that just because you're
Indigent in one County doesn't
necessarily mean you're Indigent in
another County and also um because
you're just because you're Indigent for
a lawyer doesn't mean you can't afford
electron monitoring and since each
program is different in terms of what
they ask to reimburse so some counties
just ask for the reimbursement of the
bracelets some counties include the cost
of the bracelet the software the
hardware and the Personnel to manage
that um so giving the counties as much
flexibility as possible to administer
these programs and incorporate each
unique feature for those programs would
much is there anybody else here wishing
to testify on Senate Bill 578 that has
not turned in a pink card seeing none I
will close the public hearing for Senate
Bill 578 and let me
see does the committee members need a a
few minute recess um before we open up
the next hearing or are we good we're
um I will open the public hearing for
591 and recognize the prime sponsor to
tell I didn't hear
you get hold on one second I think he
might be out in the
wow this representative sub did you want
to um take a minute and introduce the
here good afternoon everyone for the
record I am Lauren selig and I represent
Durham which is straford district 10 and
I am introducing this bill as apparently
our sponsors are not able to be here at
the moment this is Bill 591 FNA um an
act modifying definitions claim
procedures and funding related to the
Youth Development Center settlement fund
and claims
Administration um the bill significantly
modifies definitions claims procedures
and funding related to the Youth
Development Centers settlement fund and
claims Administration and I cannot take
questions because I know nothing about
this bill other than what's on the paper
but I know that we have some outstanding
it by any chance uh do we have anybody
with us that is a co-sponsor I'm I'm
looking quickly and I
don't what's
minute yeah we'll go ahead and uh being
reset just for a few minutes if anybody
quick
e
Senator representative selig introduced
the bill but clearly she just read the
title for us so um I will reopen the
public hearing for Senate B
591 and
Bradley that this is um representative
Roy's Thor I just really make fun of it
but unfortunately I needed it today
so anyway um thank you very much
apologize for being across the street
we're all trying to do too much with too
little
time so I would like
to introduce four committee members a
letter from the attorneys that are
involv
this so as I for the record Jeb Bradley
Senate District 3 appreciate um the
opportunity to testify on behalf of
Senate Bill 591 want to thank all the
bipartisan Co sponsors that are on this
bill and talk about the importance of
the bill I think anybody that's been
following the recent trial knows exactly
how important this bill is um my good
friend and colleague Karen
umberger um filed the first legislation
House Bill 1677 as I recall in 2022 that
started the settlement process um as you
will hear from the attorney General I
think later this afternoon the
settlement process is
proceeding um but there are some
significant changes that should be made
to improve that process that will better
enable um the clients of the attorneys
that are here today from Nixon peid and
Riley Associates uh to be able to
recommend
that the people they represent enter the
settle process as opposed to the
litigation process if there are some
1,000 cases maybe more um if they were
not to settle on a large number of those
it would clog our courts up um for years
with unknown outcomes um in the
litigation process unknown outcomes
could mean a huge um expenditure for the
state that is not
only not able to be determined but not
able to be managed therefore both sides
have come together um as they did a
couple of years ago to negotiate the
first uh settlement process and they've
come back with I think what is a more
comprehensive approach that will better
enable um as they say in this letter the
improved process
to uh to recommend ending the improved
process to the vast majority of our
clients as appropriate based on the
facts and circumstances of each case
there will probably be some cases as
there is the case currently right now
that will go through the court system
but if we can um pass this bill as is um
I think it will better enable us to
manage this process so if I can um touch
on the high points of the bill
um there is a new
definition on the first page of the bill
on line 15 egregious sexual
abuse so egregious sexual abuse is will
be a heightened term that will be
eligible for a heightened
settlement that's the first big change
on line 25 physical abuse would change
to other abuse with some of the
criteria um outlined on lines 28 27 28
and 29 unlawful restraint strip
um there is a change where you would
have a cause of action for an invasion
of privacy
that's lines five and six there's a
definition of unlawful strip search and
again I'm just hitting the highlights
because um this is a long Bill and you
can ask questions
um so on page three a very important
criteria is that um the payout would be
payable under terms and conditions is
determined by the administrator accepted
by the claim it subject to the
limitations of the statute so that
better
defines um the role of the administrator
and how payouts would happen um the bill
on line 18 on page three allows for
assistant administrators I think Justice
bradrick um is doing a very good job
under trying circumstances but with what
I think everybody hopes for acceleration
of the process of more settlement cases
there will be a need for more um folks
to work with the um Justice
um on line 28 number four aggravating
and mitigating factors was already in
the statute but um there is new language
added about multiple forms of sexual and
on page five um as I said before
egregious sexual abuse would be eligible
for instead of a maximum $1.5 million
settlement it would be eligible up to
$2.5
million um for egregious sexual abuse
and other abuse would increase from
150,000 to 200
50,000 these new numbers while yes
higher will enable more settlements more
settlements equals more predictability
for the state over a longer term and
ability for the State of New Hampshire
to be able to manage its budget and meet
the um need for closure and compensation
for these victims that were the subject
of some pretty
significant um and horrific abuse under
care they're on page six on line
11 the date for filing for settlements
is extended to June 30th of 2025 it's
currently the end of this year that will
allow a little bit more time given that
we are making
changes
um
then there are numerous places where
other abuse um as opposed to physical
abuse comes in for instance at the
33 also at the top of page seven but you
see that numerous times so I'm going to
um
flip to page
nine uh actually
10 um new language has been
added on page 10 excuse me line 18 and
line 17 about investigations being
conducted in a trauma informed
respectful and dignified manner um this
is obviously part of the settlement to
make sure that victims are treated
appropriately because that's what they
victims again um hitting the highlights
on page 11 the Attorney General design
and the claiming or claimants may also
engage in discussions to resolve claims
sense so at the bottom of um page 12 is
a um provision that allows a claim to be
installments which is very important in
the managing of our budget situation um
we are projecting in this bill and that
would mean please turn to page um
that approx imately $75
million um would need to be appropriated
in any given fiscal year so the Attorney
General can probably give more upto-date
numbers but my understanding is there
are well over a 100 cases that have
settled at about
$450 to
$500,000 on average per claim so I think
you can see the need for managing the
budget process for to the state while at
the same time protecting the
rights of the victims and the
compensation on line 20 the
administrator will have
discretion within available
Appropriations to determine whether a
claim should be paid as a lump
sum or in increments over a several year
period again this is a budget
management um
tool there on line 26 in order to make
that fair for the
victim a 5% interest um will go along
with the the extended payments as
opposed to a lump sum payment that was
um a agreed upon percentage between the
Attorney General's office and the
attorneys from Nix and PE buy I think
that's fair given that there could be
extended um
settlements
um so I think I skipped over a little
bit uh the $75 million that's what's
anticipated that the administrator could
not authorize more than 75 million in
any fiscal year but the administ rator
um is allowed to ask the fiscal
committee to um exceed that amount
necessary
um on page
[Music]
14 um this again talks about what
happens if the administrator feels
believes there's a shortfall in the
settlement fund um to after consultation
with the attorney general um can make a
request of an additional
appropriation on lines 22 and 20 through
24 um the state treasurer is authorized
with the approval of the fiscal
committee to borrow if that becomes
necessary hopefully it never becomes
necessary because we're trying to design
a process
manages the
Appropriations and then the last
uh um critical piece and I apologize I
was using the bill as introduced um I'll
go to the senate pass version the only
amendment that the Senate made to the
bill um was on page 19 adding the $60
million
appropriation um on line 19 that was at
the recommendation of the Attorney
General's office this is a uh large
amount of money on top of the100 million
that's already been
segregated from the rainy day fund for
purposes of trying to resolve this so um
I apologize for taking a long amount of
time I just want to walk through the
highlights and again stress the
importance of a um unless there's
agreement between the attorney General's
office and the attorneys that this is a
package and it holds together because
there was cooperation um and quite
frankly both sides should be
congratulated for the cooperation that
they've um exhibited so please no
amendments unless both sides have agreed
to an amendment that doesn't mean there
may not be good ideas but please um this
is a settlement piece of legislation and
again um this allows
us to do right by victims but at the
same time protect the longer term
Financial Health of the state that's a
very difficult task for all of us and I
think that's why the Senate voted for
this 24 to nothing because I think
people on both sides of the aisle have
seen this as a way to resolve these
egregious problems of the past doing
right by victims but but protecting the
state so happy to answer any questions
chair representative
Muse I I did have one question and for
forgive my ignorance on this but are
settlements are not not settlements but
are judgments that are independent of
the settlement process paid out of the
settlement fund or do they come from
another fin that's probably the Attorney
General could better answer than me but
my understanding is the attorney general
or already has the authority to make
settlement cases up to I believe it's
$475,000 if an attorney general deems
that is in the best interest of the
state and it would be outside of this
you representative Harry
gather thank you madam chair um on page
19 you mentioned can you tell me again
what was on page 19 because what I have
only goes up to I believe 16 so I just
wanted to capture what you said I think
that was in the original
maybe I think I said 19 and I apologize
I should have said 15 so the amendment
that the Senate adopted was on page 15
l19 um the $60 million appropriation on
top of the $100 million that the
previous legislature put into a
dedicated fund for this
purpose thank you
mhm seeing no further questions thank
good afternoon Madame chair members of
the committee my name is mikal caner I'm
counsel with the law firm Nixon
Peabody I along with my colleagues Dave
venanzo Mark Knights Dan Dean and Russ
Riley of rileyan Associates represent
over, 1300 victims who suffered sexual
physical and other kinds of abuse at
wide DC and other state
facilities my colleagues wish that they
could be here today although they are
unable to attend because they're
currently representing our client David
mean in the first trial against the
state for YDC
abuse I'm testifying today in favor and
in support of this bill because it makes
meaningful changes to the settlement
fund that we believe will make the fund
more attractive to to our clients the
victims I submitted a written testimony
today that I will Briefly summarize um I
lead the legal team at Nixon pebody and
riing Associates um that team helps uh I
I lead the team excuse me that helps
clients submit claims into the
settlement process and represent those
clients through all stages of the
settlement fund
process however to date a small
percentage of our clients have actually
submitted claims to the fund and that's
for a variety of reasons including the
fact that the Caps are too low on
compensation in the current uh form of
the program and also because the program
only compensates victims for a limited
scope of abuse and by that I mean
strictly sexual abuse and physical abuse
um it's also problematic that the
current fund is cumbersome uh time
consuming um and at times not victim
friendly however the bill before this
committee addresses those issues and I'd
like to take a moment to thank the
Attorney General's office for their
cooperation um in coming to these
compromises that are reflected in the
bill before the committee um namely
those include um increased caps like you
heard uh Senator Bradley refer to um
caps on sexual abuse um and caps on um
other abuse um other abuse is a
significant compromise in this bill um
whereas the current fund only
compensates for sexual abuse and
physical abuse the improvements that are
recommended in the bill would make it so
that there's a category of sexual abuse
and other abuse and other abuse would
Encompass not only physical abuse but
other types of abuse such as solitary
endangerment and so we support this bill
for our clients because um it makes it
so that our clients feel validated feel
that their abuse um is validated I've
heard from clients who are so encouraged
at the prospect that they could receive
compensation for the very lengthy
solitary confinement that they endured
at YDC and the other state facilities
I've spoken with victims of egregious
sexual abuse that feel validated that
there could now be a cap of $2.5 million
uh for what they went through
and while not all of our clients are
excited to talk about what happened to
them most of them are certainly eager to
settle their claims as quickly as
possible and this bill provides the
framework for a much more expeditious
process uh including because it permits
the administrator to appoint assistant
administrators which would speed up the
processing of individual
claims overall we support the changes in
the bill we encourage the committee to
pass it and as our letter to Senator
Bradley indicated um if this bill is
enacted we anticipate recommending the
fund to the vast majority of our clients
as appropriate based on the facts and
circumstances of each case thank you and
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you for your testimony I
don't see no questions thank you very
much thank you
Mr attorney
[Music]
general thank you madam chair uh members
of the committee good afternoon uh just
for the record John formela attorney
general um whenever I speak about this
topic whether it's in front of the
legislature or anywhere else I always
just like to start by acknowleding ing
the difficulty of the topic and the
difficulty of the material and
acknowledge what the victims that we're
speaking about have been through I think
it's always important to to keep in mind
that you know we we have a lot of people
involved here and each one has a a
different story and it's important to
remember that they're each individuals
and so while you know with a with a case
like this that involves so many victims
we just try not to lose lose sight of
that um just take a moment want to
remind the committee as well that you
know as attorney
general for something like this I play a
really unique role because I have to
oversee both the office's civil
litigation function and the criminal
investigation the criminal prosecutions
so that that is a you know it's
something that has been discussed in the
Press it's a concept that I admit can be
difficult to Grapple with um it is just
part of the very unique role that we
play at the Attorney General's office
office and we we take our
responsibilities very seriously to try
to separate those functions and to
perform both of those functions in good
faith and on behalf of the people of the
state but it does it will perhaps limit
some of the questions I can answer I'll
take all every question you have at at
the end of my remarks but it may limit
me and what what I can answer and what I
can say but I just like to to put that
out there and remind members of the
committee of
that as many of you will recall we uh
came to the legislature in 2022 to
establish the YDC uh claims fund and
settlement process at the time over 400
victims had come forward so even in 2022
we already knew that this was a major
undertaking and we were dealing with a
situation in which many people as who uh
we're dealing with the situation
involving many people who are suffered
some Terrible Things terrible abuse
physical and sexual abuse as children
while in state
custody when we brought this to the
legislature in 2022 we also made clear
that we still didn't know the full scope
of what we were dealing with and we
didn't think we were going to know the
full scope of what we were dealing with
for some
time we also talked about the fact
that these are difficult cases and
difficult stories to hear and grapple
with for a number of reasons one of
course is the just the uh the terrible
stories you hear about abuse that that
kids suffered in state custody um what
also makes it difficult is that this
happened many many years ago and so
cases involving sexual assault
especially and cases involving sexual
assault of kids are incredibly difficult
um to
to investigate and prosecute or to
evaluate for purposes of civil
litigation if they happened very
recently they're all the more difficult
to address and deal with if they've
happened many years ago so we talked
about that when we had brought this
forward back in
2022 um and then of course we talked
about the um difficulty of assessing
really what the legal exposure is to the
state when you're dealing with
potentially at the time hundreds and now
over a thousand cases so I say all of
that just to um emphasize that this
is I look at this as an incredibly
important piece of legislation and I
look at this process as incredibly
important for the state not just to
limit the state's exposure in litigation
but to um make right what was a terrible
wrong that was done to to many kids in
state custody of
course all situations are unique and all
victims had their own experience and
every particular case needs to be vetted
based on the facts of that case but when
you think of this in totality um again
it's it's difficult for a lot of reasons
we also recognized at doj that the
traditional litigation process can be
difficult right and that's what led to
establishing this process and based on
all of those things we recommended in
2022 that we establish this claims fund
and settlement process as an alternative
to traditional litigation um as an
alternative to a process that can be
very difficult for anyone who may have
to interact with the court system but
can be especially difficult for someone
who was the victim of physical or sexual
abuse as a
child so the legisl ped hb1 1677 in 2022
and it set up the process we have
today um I I am
very you know there it can be difficult
to find the right words but I'm proud of
the work that we have done as a state in
current times to to address this
situation
um I I think that the state
should you know should should take pride
in the fact that we have confronted a
wrong that took place many years ago and
that we are doing our best as Senator
Bradley said to try to respect the need
to compensate victims respect the um the
rights and dignity of victims while
protecting the state's bottom line and
the state's ability to to budget to date
we've resolved 147 claims for a total of
about $715 million and the average claim
paid so far is about
$486,000 that average has been pretty
consistent throughout the process so
that just gives you a sense of of the
numbers um and I think while we can
expect those numbers to continue to move
that generally Falls in fact below the
projections we made in 2022 so 147
claims resolved to date 71.5 million an
$486,000 uh as Council for Nixon puddy
or accounts for the from Nixon pey for
the plaintiffs mentioned when we were
having these negotiations back in 202 22
there since the process has begun there
have been
three primary topics that have prevented
many claimants from coming into the
fund the first is that the Caps were too
low the second is that the scope was too
limited and that the third is that the
process was overly complex and
burdensome so last fall we began
negotiations we reopened negotiations
with Nixon puddy and and Russ Riley
because we wanted to take another shot
at getting to agreement on something
that could provide a fair and reasonable
and more victim centered and Trauma
informed approach for the vast majority
of the victims involved in this case and
we spent months with those negotiations
and what you see before you today is a
product of um difficult but respectful
negotiations um sometimes contentious
but I think always conducted in good
faith so I want to certainly thank Nixon
peab buddy and Russ Riley specifically
Dave venanzo Mark Knights Dan Dean
certainly want to thank attorney caner
for her involvement in the process and I
want to thank those from my team who
have been involved Matt Broadhead is
here today Sam Garland is here today Jen
Ramsey here today they're all with my
office this and I certainly want to
thank Senator Bradley and all the
legislators involved at crafting what
sits before you as as a compromise it is
it is a true compromise in that there
are pieces in this bill that if I could
write the bill the way I wanted to write
it or write a settlement process the way
I wanted to write it I wouldn't have in
there and there are certainly pieces in
the bill that if plaintiff's council
wanted to to put or that plaintiff's
council probably didn't want in there
and there are pieces that they wanted in
there that didn't make it in it is a
true compromise that that sits before
you and it is a collective uh best
effort to address a very difficult
situation we do not claim it is perfect
by any means but what I can represent to
you in my role as attorney general is I
think this is a very good faith effort
to address a very difficult and complex
uh problem and to make right a wrong
that was done to many victims so I don't
want to repeat too much what you've
already heard because Senator Bradley
gave you a lot of details of what the
bill does I just want to hit a couple
high points and then I'll be happy to
take questions
but as I mentioned one of the big issues
with the previous or with the current
process is that the Caps were too low
that was one of the issues that
plaintiffs had raised so this bill
raises the cap for abuse that would fall
into the category of egregious sexual
abuse from 1.5 million to $2.5
million there's a definition of
egregious sexual abuse in the bill it is
generally defined as sexual abuse that
is um just of a nature that's much worse
than most other instances of sexual
abuse that you've seen from victims that
have come forward who who are at YDC
ultimately the the determination will
need to be made by the administrator
administrator John bradrick so there's
discretion left to the administrator but
that's the general definition of
egregious sexual
abuse there's a number of other factors
listed in the bill that you you uh the
administrator can look at to determine
whether something's egregious I won't
read through them but I'm happy to
answer question questions on
them the definition of sexual abuse was
also expanded to include things like
indecent exposure um invasion of privacy
a common law invasion of privacy I just
point out that not all sexual abuse is
valued the same so while the category of
sexual abuse is expanded in the current
guidelines you know the worst forms of
sexual abuse are valued at
$200,000 and um as you go down the list
the lowest value is
$25,000 saying all that of course it's
important to acknowledge that there's
really no dollar amount you can put on
this type of abuse right and there it I
think we all have sort of this gut
negative reaction to even putting a
number on on something like this but
that that is the way the law compensates
for injury it compensates with with
dollars and so we're doing our best to
put a dollar number on it um but in
reality no amount of money could ever
truly compensate for abuse like
this as attorney caner as attorney caner
mentioned we also expand sort physical
abuse so we remove the category of
physical abuse and it now includes other
abuse so other abuse includes the
physical abuse that's in the current
process so it includes what already was
listed as physical abuse but we add a
few things like Reckless conduct
criminal threatening child endangerment
unlawful strip searches intentional
Affliction of emotional distress and
unlawful restraint again this is a this
is a compromise I know when we talked
about the bill in 2022 some of these
categories of abuse we decided not to
include but we have I would say a couple
things to that one we have a lot more
information now two years later about
what happened at YDC based on the claims
that have come through through we've
heard a lot of stories um and we have
you know it it can be difficult to talk
about these things in the abstract it it
you really get a better understanding of
what happened when you hear stories from
specific victims and it was based on
those stories and based on discussions
with plaintiff's council um that we made
the decision to include these categories
of abuse again the cap on other abuse is
$250,000
so the cap on sexual abuse that's not
egregious remains 1.5 million while we
have sort of expanded the other category
from physical abuse to other abuse and
added additional things the cap goes up
from $150,000 to
$250,000 for that category but it's
still just
$250,000 so I say that to just remind
the committee that there's still sort of
tear of the values of the various
categories of
abuse for solitary confinement which
which was a major uh topic of discussion
the first time we discussed this in 2022
the cap on that is
$150,000 so we felt it was important to
acknowledge those victims who who
suffered in
unreasonably uh
long um periods of solitary confinement
we felt that it was important to
acknowledge and compensate for that
plaintiff's council have have shared
with us studies that show that that can
be really damaging to to a child but at
the same time we you know we cap that
$150,000 the other two big things that
this bill does and this again represents
the compromise in exchange for expanding
the scope and increasing the Caps the
bill now provides that the administrator
can decide that a claim could be paid
over a period of years and the the
reasons for this are are really two one
there's a state interest in spreading
out these payments over time because
while we acknowledge that we need to do
the right thing by these victims and we
need to pay Fair compensation there's a
reality to what the state can do
financially and so this bill allows for
some claims to be paid out over a period
of years it caps the administrator's
Authority I should say it obligates the
administrator to monitor the fund
balance and caps his authority uh to
make payouts at no more than $75 million
in any one fiscal year that number could
go up for a particular fiscal year if he
can come and get if he comes and gets
approval from the executive counsel and
the fiscal committee I should say the
governor and counsel and the fiscal
committee but it generally imposes that
$75 million Pere cap in order to enable
the state to have some
predictability and then as Senator
Bradley mentioned there's a 5% interest
for payments made made over time the
bill also addressed is uh making the
process more efficient and you know
really the the major thing it does with
that is that it it removes some of the
mandatory timelines or gives more
flexibility on the timelines but it also
and this is very
important um removes the obligation of
the Attorney General's office the
Attorney General's design to take a
position on a claim
before a claimant has had their uh
um their uh Hearing in front of the
administrator and the reason why that's
important is this right now we at the
Attorney General's office take a
position on a claim often before we've
ever seen or heard from the
claimant and I think anyone who's worked
with victims can tell you that without
either you yourself talking to a victim
or you yourself at least being able to
listen to what a victim is saying listen
to to what they have to say in their own
words hear them testify it is very
difficult to assess credibility and
really think about how a claim should be
valued the way this bill changes the
process we will have much more of an
opportunity to to do that to at least
listen to a victim's testimony before we
take a position on a claim and I think
that's going to be really valuable for
the
process again the bill also extends the
filing deadline to June 30th 2025 I
think that's going to be important
because we're going to have to rewrite
the guidelin lines um the last point I
will make and again there's a lot more I
could cover here and I've already talked
really longer than I intended to but
there's a lot of information here I just
want to make sure you have it because
it's an important bill but um the the
last point I will make is is
this
the there's
no I said it before there's no amount of
money that can truly compensate for what
happened to somebody for abuse you
suffer for as a child there's just no
amount of money that can truly
compensate for that and there is an
understandable desire for for many
people myself included to want to be
sure that we
are that we're determining what happened
to each victim with with enough
certainty that we're paying the right
amount of money um for a situation like
this that involves so many victims that
happened so many years ago
never going to land we're never going to
land on a perfect process right this
this is per Perfection will never be
something that we can achieve with this
but I think our goal as a state should
be to to make the best good faith effort
we can to pay some Fair compensation to
people who suffered terrible abuse while
in state care at the same time
understanding that this is never going
to be a perfect process but we need to
do the best we can
I think if we if we look at this
legislation look at this process with
that philosophy in mind then I think my
hope would be that you would see the
product you have before you as as an
attempt to do that and as a fair
compromise among people who have really
worked hard in good faith to come to a
process that can be a good alternative
for the vast majority of victims um with
that I'm happy to take questions and I
appreciate you listening to my uh long
explanation and long set of
remarks um I I just have um a question
so as an example where where the term
egregious sexual abuse is in here is
this a is this something that will just
be a permanent a permanent new
definition and statute no so this is a
definition solely for purposes of the
YDC okay yeah settlement process okay so
um someday when we when this process has
concluded this statute will disappear so
this is not a permanent definition okay
thank you yeah representative
Newman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um I'm just
trying to understand this this isn't a
judicial process this won't take place
in court could you just give us a
nutshell like somebody files a claim
sure then when do you get the testimony
and how does the administrator and who
is he how do he get there and
what happens so that they go through and
pick this one and that one and whatever
to come up with a solution for that
particulars absolutely thank you
representative yes so this this is
separate from the judicial process it's
meant to be an alternative to that
because uh I think as many of you
probably know or at least can can um
ascertain uh if you file a lawsuit it
takes years often to get it resolved
right and this is so this is meant to be
a a much more efficient way to resolve a
claim so at a high
level a claimant submits a claim form
and there's a CL we went through this
whole process in 2022 to develop what
the claim form looks like claim and
submits a claim form to the
administrator's office the administrator
determines makes a determination on when
it's complete there might be a back and
forth between the administrator's office
and the claim in if there's missing
information and the goal is really to to
help help get all the information in the
form that necessary to to look at the
claim um the way the process works right
now is once a claim form is complete it
gets sent to the Attorney General's
office and the Attorney General's design
reviews the claim and we take a position
on what what we think the value should
be and we can have a back and forth
discussion with the claimant and if we
can come to an agreement then the case
we just settle the case if we can't come
to an agreement then it's submitted to
the administrator for for a for a
hearing process and the administrator
will ultimately make a decision on the
value of the claim the way that we value
the claim and the way the administrator
values the claim is by using the
guidelines that we developed back in
2022 and those guidelines set out um
what different instance incidents of
abuse are are worth from a monetary
perspective so um I hate to use the word
formula for something like this but it's
kind of like a formula so we use a
worksheet or claimant uses a worksheet
we kind of use the same worksheet the
administrator uses the same worksheet if
if he has to decide the claim but that
is at a high level generally the process
our goals to have it take no more than
six
months
followup yeah my only followup would be
so you have you you have some kind of
formula that was developed in 2022 and
then this bill just amends the various
values and things and puts in new
definitions so it's a combination of
what you had in 2022 as amended by this
bill and then that process as you
described it yes thank you and and just
to just to clarify for you um at risk of
giving you more information than you
asked for the the guidelines and and the
claim form that were developed in 2022
that was separate for the leg from the
legislation we had to draft those in
consultation with clayman's Council and
then get them approved by the fiscal
committee if this bill passes will have
to do the same thing because there are
changes being made in the legislation
we'll have to go back through the fiscal
committee working with climens Council
and now the administrator to amend those
guidelines and that formula and that
worksheet and in order for this bill
really to truly take effect thank you
that helps a lot yep representative
Harry
gther thank you madam chair um my
question is um the administrator since
they have the opportunity to make the
decisions the final decision um is there
anything in there say if a person is 60
versus 40 and um just a question if
you're 60 your lifespan is probably a
little bit shorter and if you're 40
might be a little longer so is there
anything in there that says that based
on age or something that um that might
help to form the decision rather to pay
immediately or go over spand of time
yeah so serous yeah thank you for the
question I think it's it's a really good
one yeah it's ultimately up to the
administrator as to whether to award a
claim in a lump sum or have the claim
paid out over a period of years and
while there's no set list of criteria
that the administrator has to consider
when deciding that he has discretion and
I can tell you in talking with
plaintiff's counsil and talking with the
administrator I think that's certainly
something that would be taken into
account whether someone is older or we
have had claim in who who might be ill
and may not think they have a very long
life expectancy and I think in those
situations that certainly would be more
likely to either be a lump sum or at
least a payment maybe over two or three
years as opposed to five or six thank
you y representative
Pratt hello thank you for the questions
um I have a question has anybody since
this all started the reporting has any
children passed
away has any of these 1400 people passed
away
so I I don't know that off the top of my
head what I can tell you is that the way
we have what the way the bill addresses
that is once a claim is filed if someone
passes away their estate can continue
with the claims process um if you
haven't filed a claim yet the estate
can't file a claim they can't but I
don't know whether anyone has has passed
away on that note you know I can um and
this addresses I think representative
Muse's question from earlier outside of
this process the attorney general has
the authority to settle settle any case
and the cap is actually it's quite a bit
higher than Senator Bradley mentioned
the cap is all the way up to um I think
it's you know 1/4 of 1% uh for a
particular claim or case 1/4 of 1% of
the previous year's uh general fund
revenues so that's about up to $5
million for a case so we have a lot of
flexibility to settle a case even
outside of this process and we would
always consider I mean the job of the
Department of Justice is always to
consider the interests of justice and if
there were a unique case like that we
would certainly or for that reason or
for another reason we would consider
using that authority to to do justice
you representative
scitec I can't resist did formala
developed the
formula uh prob would you agree that the
most important part of your testimony is
bradick I would say that I yeah I think
it's important that the
administrator is someone like John
bradrick who served as the Chief Justice
of the Hampshire Supreme Court and is
you know clearly I think respected in
the bar so yeah yeah I think that who
the administrator is is always an
important question and yes the fact that
it's John bradick someone that the state
trusted to be the Chief Justice of our
Supreme Court should give people
work all right see no more questions
thank you very much for your testimony
today thank you
is there anybody else wishing to testify
on this bill that is not turned in a
pain card seeing none I will close the
public hearing for Senate Bill
591 and um I will open the public
hearing for the non- gerain amendment
Senate Bill
563 and I'm going to recess um Senate
Bill
563 until Monday April 22nd at 10
o'clock
um with that I will close that P public
hearing and